salut à tous ça va très bien et merci
tout pour ce petit décompte on serait
cru en grande production donc c'était
c'était sympa ce démarrage à la
Spielberg que tu m'as fait mais en tout
cas ça va très bien écoute je trouve que
j'ai une petite activité sportive ce
matin j'ai fait une petite publication
pour pour ça j'ai pas eu l'occasion de
voir mais je t'en ai un petit peu parlé
toi tu es dans le secret des sages
évidemment et on va voir des grosses
grosses parties je pense aujourd'hui que
ça va être une ronde où ça peut partir
en freestyle parce qu'il y a des très
jolies matchs alors du coup on va aller
on va aller voir directement alors je
vais vous montrer ça direct regardez on
a un goût cache contre so Wesley donc
une partie assez intéressante sauf qu'il
vient de battre gamer à la route
précédente et Google qui est toujours
dans le mal qui est à la recherche de sa
première victoire
donc voyons voir si Lucas arrive la
pression à ce match
il peut en fait j'ai des interrogations
par rapport à Google c'est par rapport à
KMR avec les Blancs qui sont en grande
difficulté qui sont plutôt des joueurs
au sens ce sont des jeunes qui veulent
prendre de l'expérience mais à leur
place psychologiquement je serai un
petit peu atteint sauf et dans ces
cas-là avec les Blancs tu as envie aussi
de sécuriser ton ouverture et pas partir
en freestyle total donc quel va être
l'attitude à ton avis de ces deux jeunes
ils vont jouer comme d'habitude ils vont
réussir à passer le pas et à envoyer ou
pas
[Musique]
je pense que il joue la en tournoi
c'est difficile de se mettre dans la
tête d'un joueur comme ça mais je pense
vraiment que Google par exemple il prend
sa chance et il veut toutes les parties
à fond comme
je pense qu'il en fait je pense qu'il va
essayer de d'activer un petit peu la
défaite tu vois pas trop y penser et de
continuer le tournoi tu vois avant
d'après ronde et devenir vraiment donner
le meilleur qui peut à chaque fois je
sais que les Indiens de manière générale
sont assez sont vraiment bon
psychologiquement tu vois et ils
arrivent vraiment à installer ça je peux
faire l'année dernière qui avait bientôt
un difficile bien sûr et ben il avait
quand même bien terminé c'était pas
ridicule du tout
et je pense clairement les joueurs sont
vraiment forts là-dedans ils ont des
coachs mentaux etc il y a un an qui est
sur place aussi on a vu et en tout cas
je pense que enfin moi je les vois jouer
pour le gain je pense pas que c'est une
répète Google qui va tomber dans
directement c'est pas du tout ce que je
pense et je pense qu'il va y avoir du
fight et toi petite personnelle je sais
que moi si je perds 2 rondes de switch
je parle un peu tout seul et j'ai du mal
à m'y remettre je dirais après comment
je fais mais toi comment ça se passe
tout tu arrives à faire le deuil de deux
défaites consécutives et repartir par
exemple ou comment tu te situes ben j'ai
eu des à ce niveau là j'ai eu des hauts
et des bas c'est vrai que dans ma
carrière ça n'arrivait plus d'une fois
de perdre de partie d'affilée
et bon des fois c'est juste le tilt et
d'ailleurs très souvent j'ai eu des
phases où j'ai eu du mal à me remettre
parce que Ton a été fichu etc etc mais
au final je pense qu'en fait un conseil
que je donne souvent aux enfants en fait
aux enfants parce que je suis en train
de souvent des enfants que d'autres en
fait c'est que du coup le tournoi par 0
imaginons tu commences avec 0 sur 2 et
ben en fait essayer de te dire bon ok il
reste cette ronde en fait tu fais un
tournoi sur cette ronde qui commence
aujourd'hui tu vois et voilà et en fait
essayer de cacher un peu ça
psychologiquement pour pour
essayer de de
motiver un peu l'élève donc c'est vrai
que c'est quand même pas facile en tant
que coach et puis ce conseil là est tout
à fait valable évidemment mais tu
espères que le résultat va être nul ou
victoire parce que si c'est encore des
fêtes tu peux redonner
donc après bien sûr quand j'étais parti
en Inde tu sais que j'étais parti en
Inde avec le Club de Cannes il y a
quelques années
donc j'avais rencontré pour la première
fois Prague à ce moment-là par exemple
et bien sûr ramènes je l'entraîneur de
Prague et en fait il nous disait un truc
intéressant si tu veux en fait les
enfants ils ont des objectifs qui sont à
la fois courts et à la fois sur le long
terme par exemple
c'est qu'il voulait avoir 2900 Hainaut
tu vois et
ouais bon il avait 13 ans quand je l'ai
vu il avait 2500 quasiment et en fait il
voulait avoir 2900 et sur le court terme
il voulait grand maître voilà il était
pas encore maître et tu vois et donc du
coup chaque
on va dire élève avait ses objectifs
court terme moyen terme long terme
et du coup ben les défaites ben ça fait
partie du jeu en fait tu vois par
rapport à cet objectif ok tu vas aller
un petit peu de l'objectif court terme
mais tu restes quand même dans
l'objectif long terme donc il faut
perdre progresser etc il faut comprendre
et après c'est pas évident de l'accepter
malgré tout mais tu vois le fait d'avoir
le objectif sur le long terme ça peut
être intéressant de pour le fait
d'accepter un peu tout ça
et j'avais un conseil hyper intéressant
qui peut servir à tout le monde puisque
je l'ai utilisé c'est un compte un
conseil de mon collègue Jean-Noël Rif
donc il y a aussi mon capitaine d'équipe
qui est qui est grand maître qui a un
style très pratique et il entraînait
beaucoup ses stylocerneaux à l'époque
qui avait fait des gros résultats dans
les compétitions internationales et il
arrivait qu'elle se craque quoi elle
était pas tout le temps dominante non
plus dans sa catégorie et du coup c'est
arrivé qu'elle soit favorite dans la
catégorie et qu'elle fasse vraiment un
sale tournoi et souvent le Conseil qui
lui donnait c'était de donner des
ouvertures
un peu atypique pour qu'elle se fasse
plaisir dans une ronde où il y avait
vraiment aucun enjeu bam nouvelle
ouverture prépa du matin
vraiment entre guillemets risqué dans le
sens voilà tu vas te faire plaisir tu
vas jouer un Gambie tu vas jouer quelque
chose comme ça et je sais qu'à titre
personnel j'avais utilisé ce conseil là
dans un tournoi où on est en maître
j'avais fait deux bulles de suite contre
grand maître et maître en étant deux
fois très bien en plus donc j'étais deg
et j'avais joué justement le début
jobava pour me faire plaisir tu vois
et j'avais gagné une partie enfin une
des plus jolies parties que j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire où j'avais mis mon
roi dans le camp adverse alors qu'il
restait dame et de Tours la partie était
hyper kiffante et du coup ça s'était
bien passé mais bon là le scénario est
bon j'aurais pu très bien me faire
bâcher dans l'ouverture et là je te
dirai pas ça aujourd'hui mais je trouve
que le conseil quand même assez
pragmatique est assez intéressant de te
faire plaisir dans l'ouverture ça peut
être une clé c'est ça après à ce niveau
là un truc Google fais sauce un peu plus
difficile de trouver des ouvertures un
petit peu
mais sinon c'est vrai que c'est un bon
conseil
le fait de prendre des risques ça peut
être chaud surtout à ce niveau là
imaginons bouquet je choisis tout
envoyer il se fait retourner
le bon style quand même pour faire un
des ouvertures un peu plus olé
il a vraiment battu tu l'as bien cerné
je pense hier avec ce que tu disais dans
une position où je trouvais que c'était
très difficile de jouer lui il a trouvé
tous les bons coups et c'était hyper
intéressant de bout en bout avec son
schéma avec grand rock qui pour l'ordi
ne va pas mais lui il a il a vraiment
joué à un niveau exceptionnel je trouve
ça partie d'hier contre lyrique très
très fort dans ce genre de position
c'est vraiment ce que je pense que le
mot c'est le mot qui décrit bien régalé
c'est acrobate
donc du coup les appareils
so on avait parram contre karwana donc
par hamkerware
qui est en tête de tournoi enfin en fait
on peut faire les pronoms en même temps
au fur et à mesure pour changer un petit
peu ce serait sympa
alors on va trouver aussi les caméras
j'ai oublié de mettre les petits trucs
là
alors donc prono chaud
alors Google
je vais prendre ça j'ai failli mettre
nulle nul moi je voulais mettre nul
toute façon
ça peut me
[Musique]
de pas l'influencer mais tout à l'heure
juste avant le live elle m'a dit de
toute façon je vais mettre que des
blancs et du coup ça m'influence
carrément ça m'influence carrément du
coup il est hyper mal quoi en fait j'ai
dit que des blancs mais juste comme ça
mais c'est pas vrai
et je vais mettre des plusieurs états
décisifs ça c'est clair
j'ai hyper hâte à Carlsen rapporte aussi
j'espère que rapporte va jouer risqué
dans l'ouverture que ça peut être une
partie hyper kiffe aussi
de rapport
déséquilibré sur le papier avec le
champion du monde qui doit se refaire
normalement mais Richard rapporte est
extrêmement fort
très grande forest
c'est facile le résultat
il me reste bien
pour moi
le dernier on est sérieux là voilà vous
savez à chaque fois c'est le moment des
pronos
juste avant que ça commence ça devrait
commencer dans une minute
du coup
allez j'ai pris un risque c'est bon j'en
ai pris plusieurs je peux dire
qu'aujourd'hui les Gumball mais bon
façon pour le sub c'est pas trop trop
gênant aussi et bonjour à tous ceux qui
viennent d'arriver propulse
arcanel drôle pas de maçonna Arnaud pas
de métal salut à tous
sur le
sur le live on a fiancé
[Musique]
de vue pour vous faire un petit coucou
01 ouais c'était pas bête 01 pas bête
aussi 1 0 pas bête mais c'est que les
meilleurs vélos là c'est pas trop embêté
là
0 ok nul
nul 01
mais je crois que j'ai un seul truc
quasiment comme toi Matthieu non
on va voir bonjour Kevin
c'est pour quel niveau
ouais c'est le grand lancement
aujourd'hui de du pack sur la colle donc
il y a une promo ce weekend pour ceux
que ça intéresse vous pouvez aller
regarder je vous mettrai le lien la pose
je le mets pas tout de suite comme ça
c'est vraiment ceux qui vont suivre qui
auront les infos et on les petits comme
ça souffle on vous oblige à rester avec
nous toute l'après midi mais vous allez
passer un très bon moment on vous assure
le niveau Lio j'ai mis niveau amateur je
considère entre 1200 et 1800 tu vas être
très bien avec ce pack là il est
possible que je fasse des niveaux
avancés avec tranche 700 2000 tu vois
ceux qui sont entre 1600 et 1800 il y a
quand même beaucoup de choses à prendre
donc mais on peut démarrer bas j'ai
essayé de faire des des choses à la fois
pédagogiques et je montre plus encore
pour pour les plus forts d'entre vous
voilà donc 121800 je pense que c'est
vraiment une bonne
une bonne tranche
ça peut convenir à tout le monde bien
sûr un joueur à 1250 il aura plus de
travail qu'un joueur à 1800 qui
mémorisera plus facilement véritablement
les lignes voilà
ok alors est-ce que tu comptes dévoile
un peu nos pronostics Kevin ça commence
yes avec plaisir tout fait on peut
peut-être montrer nos visages maintenant
ouais on va au visage on va montrer
aussi les caméras des joueurs
pour découvrir qui vont s'installer là
bien sûr lilio franchement tu peux jouer
la colle j'ai dit c'est cramique qui
jouait ça en fin de carrière donc tout
ce que je retire enfin c'est fichiers je
les crée enfin ces vidéos je l'écris
avec des parties de référence des
meilleurs joueurs donc vraiment on peut
on peut aller jusqu'à très haut et sur
ces sujets là je compte ensuite faire
des packs avancés mais c'est bien
d'avoir le pack initial voilà c'est
comme ça que je compte faire pour
justement
[Musique]
prétendre tout traité et pour tous les
niveaux dans une logique de parler à
plus de 2000-2002 quoi mais en fait à
titre personnel lilio de temps en temps
je joue la colle en match contre 2002
j'ai même joué la colle je crois contre
des grands maîtres quoi donc je crois
vraiment à cela en fait c'est ce que
j'ai dit on peut
voilà ouais jusqu'à
2000-2002 j'irai mais dans un premier
temps le pack niveau 1 on va dire le
pack niveau amateur ouais jusqu'à 1800
hello c'est bien mais il faut il faut
l'avoir pour passer au pack du sud de
toute façon voilà
pas de métal je t'ai fait plaisir j'ai
l'impression
du coup on a dit les pronos souffre
goûté chaud du coup tu as choisi qui moi
j'ai mis nul parce que ouais
il se prend pas trop la tête
ok ils montent pas grand chose en
ouverture pour l'instant
donc bon je me suis dit que c'était pas
bête
tu as mis quoi toi 01 ouais j'ai mis 01
j'ai dit prise de risque en fait tu m'as
bloqué après
il est concentré sur ses coupes de
cheveux un petit peu voilà donc hier bah
ça lui a permis d'ailleurs de revenir et
de faire une belle nul
c'est vrai que là ma news il nous fait
parler avec ses coupes de chevet
je réagis au propos de pas de métal mais
franco-belge ça me va bien parce que
j'ai joué les intercoms en Belgique
quand j'étais étudiant d'ailleurs je
suis convaincu en chauffeur de Belgique
bon j'ai joué cette ronde mais moi je
suis vaincu
mais jade j'adore
j'étais à Charleroi pour tout te dire
pas de métal et j'allais d'ailleurs au
tournoi en août très régulièrement et
l'accueil des Belges de Charleroi et
d'ailleurs parce que à l'Opel
international j'ai eu l'occasion de
discuter avec beaucoup de Belges j'ai
adoré l'esprit belge je me suis éclaté
et ça se rapproche de de ma belle
Bretagne
et je ne parle pas que de l'attrait pour
la boisson franchement
les les belles sont hyper sympathiques
et je j'ai des supers revenir de mes
passages en Belgique pour les échecs
voilà donc tu vois pâte je sais à qui je
parle tu vois je te je te caresse dans
le sens du poil comme on dit pâtes voilà
bien sûr
bien sûr j'ai joué le tournoi de
Charleroi il y a le fermé aussi à
l'époque hein je vais être tournoi fermé
à norme tournoi à norme de Grand Maître
un homme de mètres je fais 6 et demi sur
9 une fois dans le tournoi dans le
tournoi fermé il y avait une énorme A6
donc
j'avais gagné à cette époque là j'ai
oublié du coup c'était c'était il y a
longtemps c'était longtemps
qui qui fait des petites et des petites
photos voilà il y en a
qui doit commenter ou être ambassadrice
ou je sais pas quel rôle est là
exactement tu sais toi stouf je crois
qu'elle fait des interviews tout ça donc
faire la presse quoi
qu'on avait rencontré en 2003 alors que
avec Mathieu quand on avait sympathisé
avec la délégation luxembourgeoise au
cheval du monde jeune en moins de 18 ans
voilà tripez bien c'est super sympa
donc du coup alors Google show mag
caroanna qu'est-ce que tu nous as dit
tout macarona moi
[Musique]
aucune prise de risque en fait moi j'ai
mis Kawana vous voyez tout film il m'a
vendu il m'a dit je vais mettre plein de
résultats décisifs donc je me suis dit
bah les bams moi aussi je vais essayer
de je vais essayer d'y aller quoi et en
fait il m'a il m'a complètement bluffé
il a commencé par nul quoi oh là là
horrible quoi c'est pas c'est pas vrai
quoi par contre c'est une rapporte 1 m
45 ça c'est sûr donc Arsène rapport sauf
j'ai mis rapport tu as mis rapport non
c'est une blague
j'ai mis 47
il va gagner je peux vous dire
sur mes caméras là porte
salut Louta et salut à tous ceux qui
nous rejoignent et on avait une partie
de folie mais Richard rapport qui joue
la Défense russe dite défense pétrole
un choix assez peu utilisé un niveau
amateur mais je peux vous dire que c'est
un des choix que j'aime bien niveau
amateur aussi dans les E45 je l'ai pas
cité hier vous savez que j'ai une
infection pour la française la carro les
ouvertures simples le 4 5 ça fait partie
des Quatre Fantastiques qu'on a cité
hier et je trouve assez pertinent à
niveau amateur de jouer la pétrole
pourquoi parce que là encore elle est
assez peu connue elle est réputée à
annulante à haut niveau mais dans les
parties de niveau amateurs il y a pas
d'histoire on joue pour la nul on joue
pour jouer déjà
rapporte ici vient de faire le choix le
plus solide qui existe quasiment aux
échecs contre 4 il y en a d'autres mais
c'est un des choix les plus solides
avec moi regarde il met un truc hyper
bien je trouve ça te plait désolé pour
gamer c'était pas une bonne idée de le
prendre en chouchou Kevin ça va pas te
rapporter beaucoup de somme c'est pas
mal personne
je peux te dire alors que je touche avec
Abdou ça Torin il s'était pas trop
mouillé il sentait que son petit poulain
mais il l'aime bien elle se trouve c'est
pas la première fois
tu vois je l'ai pris alors que ça
première partie elle tombe pas c'est pas
un victoire mais moi jusqu'à présent
quand même à haut niveau un petit peu on
peut le dire mais juste entendu mon gars
un blitz bon même si c'est du Blitz
quand même tu vois c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais bon il a quand même un
peu plus de
très malin dans les paris je peux te
dire
et il me fait croire des trucs
incroyables pragmforest tu as dû mettre
Prague je pense
bien sûr donc j'ai mis nul tu vois parce
que parce que je savais ce que tu allais
mettre tu vois donc je me suis dit on va
changer un petit peu mince donc toi tu
as mis
du coup tu avais mis
nulmag et hop on a trois pronos sur 4
déjà qui sont différents que Carlson qui
compte pas
Erik Izzy abdosa torové
que tu allais jouer à nul donc du coup
j'ai joué ergasi
là j'ai mis nul
je me doutais mais bon je savais qu'on
aurait déjà quelques promos
et il nous reste qu'à merding
c'est ce qu'on avait déjà vu récemment
tous
oui oui plusieurs parties c'était au
speechasse mais aussi au
oui et depuis j'ai regardé en fait
depuis j'ai créé un fichier dessus
voilà parce que ça m'intéressait
et franchement en pratique elle est très
intéressante
donc l'idée elle est un peu bizarre pour
le commun des mortels on se demande un
peu ce que fait le cavalier en des trois
souffle nous a mis la petite flèche il
va aller en F4 et souvent après les
joueurs je vous décape des 5
et le cavalier F4 sera idéalement placé
pour taper le pion central et au-delà de
ça mince dame deux balles déjà je
connais plus moi super ça sert à rien de
travailler les échecs tu vois il y a
toujours des je suis dégoûté oh là là
bon bah voilà il va faire bosser autre
chose
j'imagine que j'ai regardé je crois
c'est l'autre façon de jouer il y a deux
façons de jouer et l'autre idée il y
avait l'idée cavalier F4 cavalier H5 on
peut jouer aussi avec Dame 2 dans ce cas
là il y aura peut-être une petite finale
en plus c'est plus égalisant mais quand
ça il aime bien ça
du coup kymerding tu as joué quoi
j'ai joué un peu sur les poulains je me
suis dit on va se faire plaisir et toi
tu m'as dit nul en fait moi je me suis
dit
gamer il a deux devait être d'affilée
noir je me suis dit que peut-être que
les deux n'allaient pas forcément envie
de faire Rollin
et
tu vois mais
de toute façon
voilà je me suis dit on se bat
aujourd'hui mais j'ai failli mettre un
noir
je me suis dit tu vois quand tu as mis
cette sono et que tu as une perte de
partie d'affilée tu as peut-être juste
envie d'arrêter les morrager tu vois et
du coup peut-être faire une nulle enfin
je vais très solide tu vois je suis
peut-être que ce qui va vouloir faire
donc c'est pour ça que j'aime mieux une
fois que ça nous dit que tu joues la
serrure sur les paris aujourd'hui alors
que stouf ben non je suis quand même il
m'avait il m'avait annoncé mais vraiment
des des pronos un peu fou et m'a
complètement eu alors je me suis aussi
allez je vais être sympa je vais jouer
le jeu parce que c'est bien si la
souffre quand même normalement je veux
dire c'est le beau jeu souffre quand
même des fois il perd il perd il s'en
fout il a joué beau jeu mais là il m'a
complètement escroqué et du coup je me
suis dit allez on y va aujourd'hui parce
que hier j'avais joué plus tranquille
et du coup je me suis fait je me suis
fait bananes quoi j'essaie de faire des
tu vois j'ai mis que trois raisons
j'en ai mis 5 5 ça c'est beau jeu allez
si tu veux je peux en changer hein non
non non non surtout pas surtout pas
parce qu'après si tu changes bien bah tu
sais tu es toujours vert quoi donc vaut
mieux ce que j'ai fait mettre 10 min
j'ai pas envie de changer non plus
Google ça m'a l'air bien en fait je
pense que mais je pense pas le tout pile
alors si je fais le tout pile est-ce
qu'il y a un bonus quand même
pour ceux qui fait le tour
on fait x 2 c'est 1 1
c'est juste pour le c'est quoi je crois
d'ailleurs le pari exactement là
pour le bon pronom hier tu as gagné non
non on a fait nul je sais pas en fait
je sais plus j'ai plein de post-it il
faut qu'on fasse un doc Excel c'est plus
simple
on avait c'était la R6 hier on avait les
seuls pronos différents Abdou et Hery
et ils ont fait nulle non donc personne
gagne non
aujourd'hui on fera pas match nullement
on va voir
ok
hyper intéressant c'est une variante à
la mode cette variante cavalier F4 et je
vais la regarder de ce pas mon petit
fichier parce que je l'avais mis son
échange de dames
du coup j'avais j'avais bien fripé sur
sur ce choix blanc de Magnus j'aime bien
sauf ce choix très intéressant cahier
des trois c'est un peu choquant quand
même pour pas mal de d'entre vous je
pense et donc c'était juste pour ramener
le cavalier en F4 un peu bizarre mais
l'idée
on va ramener qu'il a un petit peu
embêtant ce qu'elle va dire
ok alors si on suit l'ordre on va aller
voir un petit
erikasia
et du coup on a une position d'écossaise
[Musique]
une défense russe du coup un petit peu
la même chose
et là il y a eu des 4 c'est l'autre
façon de jouer
qui va les prendre en prise des 5 donc
il y a pas trop de surprises jusque là
ca va les prendre
c'est 5 c'est 3 car ici ce petit roc fog
G4 tours un petit rock pour savoir tout
est horrible tout ça Kevin
donc moi j'ai parié
01 on va voir ce que ça fait en tout cas
je crois à mon petit poulain
on verra bien ensuite on a une nulle
les joueurs ils ont ils ont joué des
centaines de fois ensemble franchement
c'est pas rigolo pour l'instant on peut
vous le dire
l'italienne vraiment classique
et une des lignes avec à 4 à 5 ou 3
c'est déjà assez plat
alors cette position elle est
intéressante des fois pour les pions
sans trop blancs même s'ils sont doublés
mais il y a toujours un dessin de
potentiel noir qui peut qui peut changer
la structure de pion
est-ce qu'on peut le faire d'ailleurs à
ce moment-là parce que faut 3 c'est
vraiment le truc que jouer en poussant
un stuff c'est vraiment le truc un peu
plan
on renforcerait le peut-être le centre
et demi
on se retrouve dans un deux contrats au
centre
peut-être du H6 peut-être
Lidl
mais je pense qu'il va jouer tout mou il
va pas jouer des 5 il va pas
déséquilibrer avec les Noirs parce que
là il y aurait des motifs de fou B5
aussi pour pour presser un petit peu la
structure et casser la structure avec
vous prend ceci aussi double menace donc
du coup on peut jouer tranquille sur KB2
blanc en tout cas c'est pas une partie
on risque de beaucoup s'amuser celle-là
ça tombe bien par rapport aux pruneaux
alors donc
max odlock entre karwana donc c'est un
peu la même qu'on a vu hier avec carvana
qui change de couleur alors quasiment
parce qu'il y a eu un damakache
et du coup là je sens d'abord
la mangeant un F6 puis jouer dans ma
carte
donc on voit beaucoup de ragozina en ce
moment c'est le gambidame avec le fou
qui vient en B4 ça ressemble à une limeo
indienne c'est un mix de Nîmes zoo et de
et de gambidam en fait
prise de sang prise de sang petit Rogue
il faut
comme hier c'est le même motif comme
nous disent tous avec le cavalier de
fabania Fabiano carwana qui vient
annoncer 6 ce qui est marrant sauf c'est
que lui-même a joué ce motif là hier
qui a fait très mal
on connaît le plan c'est vraiment de
mettre une tour en C1 de travailler avec
du à 3 B4
et d'envoyer sur le pion C7 voilà ça
devrait être ça le jeu le jeu blanc
travaillé sur l'aile dame
donc ça bon pour l'instant c'est pas
encore très débridé
je regarde mon prono j'ai mis karwana
pas une position très facile
pour pour jouer pour le gars
mais vraiment beaucoup de dragosines
donc tours
et pression sur la colonne C alors du
coup on a le maintenant Prague vent de
Forest à cette partie est intéressante
voilà jauge qui est déjà pas mal monté
Kevin j'espère que je suis vraiment
je me laisse pas avoir c'est ce qu'on
appelle la slash chez bananko
donc l'idée des Noirs c'est souvent B5
dans la dans la foulée d'enlever la
tension du pion de C4 un peu frustrant
et dame B3 pro qui est B5 et on fait ses
5 pour cloisonner les noirs qui n'ont
plus la rupture B6 du coup maintenant et
on peut même avoir des A4 avec les
Blancs
chacun à ces ruptures en fait
et sur 5 souvent touche à rien parce
qu'effectivement comme tu le dises tout
sinon on se fait casser notre centre des
problèmes sur ces cinq et des problèmes
de cavalier G4 qui peuvent arriver ça
dépend comment comment ça joue mais ça
va être une partie
un peu plus tendue elle est déjà plus
déséquilibrée que la position précédente
par exemple
très intéressant aussi yes ensuite on a
un goût qui est chaud donc Google
tout le tournoi qui s'est mis à E4 donc
tu parlais tout à l'heure de la fameuse
prépa où on change un peu de répertoire
et qu'on se fait plaisir donc peut-être
que tu utilises un petit peu ça
et trois petits racoutille
et là ça ressemble beaucoup plus à
l'italienne on a dû retomber d'ailleurs
dans une position d'italienne
et du coup
avec du coup la prise en dessin qui a
été joué grand classique oui de ses
positions là donc là il faut mettre une
pression en place sur E5
et dans ces positions là des fois il y a
des tours a et sur Fougères on peut
jouer h3g4 bravo mais c'est chaud
on n'est jamais revendu on fait ça quand
on gagne le pion central et encore c'est
pas sûr parce que quand ça s'ouvre
autant de faire h3g4 donc on prend bien
le problème on peut se faire
complètement complètement à voir
ok il nous reste 45 rapports on a vu
rapidement il y a eu ces 6 là on est
déjà passé et dans la partie
il nous mettait une petite question sauf
sur le fait que dans la slave on sort
pas trop le fou c'est huit il a plutôt
raison mais là dans la partie on a vu
qu'il y avait eu B5 donc on peut le
jouer de toute façon tout est jouable
forcément après faut bien le faire tu as
plutôt raison avec ta remarque en règle
générale mais sur DB3 les Noirs ont
différentes parade d'imbécis etc là
aujourd'hui c'était B5 donc c'était
jouable dans ce contexte là
elle est bonne
c'est pas très rigolo ça encore
[Musique]
début Réty puis début goûts ça s'appelle
comme ça voilà avec E3 G3
ça y est je connais plus
c'est atypique le début tout parce que
normalement je joue cette ouverture là
sans G3 quoi si tu veux c'est
déjà marginal mais début gourer chaque
G3 fougères
mais moi je
prédisais une partie
assez assez solide un document ici
pour essayer d'arrêter l'hémorragie
E4 et de d'obtenir une majorité centrale
qui commence à se mettre en marche et
qui étouffrait le joueur noir maintenant
4 si E5 est contrôlé et qu'on ne met un
fond en B7 ça devrait aller quoi
donc voir comment ça joue je ne connais
pas du tout la pollution je sais pas si
on met le fond en D2
ça existe pas trop j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu ça doit pas être improvisé
si tu veux souffre mais c'est quand même
très atypique
derrière je parie
qui attaque des trois
ce qu'on joue
F1 à la limite et B4 bon ça va je gère
la crise ouais ça a l'air d'aller
bon on verra bien
de position un peu pénible dans quel
quelle position tu veux regarder Kevin
ok il y a deux parties qui ont l'air un
petit peu plus
débridée donc il y aura pragmfort et
Carlson aussi j'ai envie de voir ce que
ça donne sous ouverture parce que j'ai
regardé il y a pas longtemps avec Dame 2
c'est marrant parce que il y a rien eu
de neuf
et ma news réfléchit alors que bon
de Richard rapporte
c'est assez thématique quand il y a la
case des 5 tu le proposais sauf du reste
tout à l'heure
ça ressemble à quelque chose de mauvais
on a l'impression qu'on peut faire dam
H4 qui est très très un piège sur
chasse.com qu'on voit tout le temps sauf
que sur damage 4 il y a contre-pied
et tu pourras pas ramasser le pion G3 le
montre hein
mais sinon le fameux cavalier prend puis
on prend d'un prank qui marche enfin
c'est le fameux problème que vous avez
vous savez en puzzle et là ça marche
4 et là on va voir cavalier F6
bon j'imagine qu'on va voir recette
c'est même pas sûr que
parce que dans 7 ça aide un petit peu
les Noirs à se développer
peut-être qu'on peut jouer juste en deux
quatre et attendre que sur les noirs qui
nous mangent eux-mêmes voilà et le F3
c'est pour mettre le roi F2 sans doute
un jour qui qui nous permettra d'avoir
un roi
qui est plus au centre pour la finale si
les dames s'échangent vous voyez que le
roi F2 c'est quand même pas mal est-ce
que tu penses que c'est par exemple
3 pour essayer de garder les dames
est beaucoup plus difficile à jouer
parce que ça donnerait un vrai fou à
l'adversaire
le problème en fait c'est que là je
trouve pas trop de coups à jouer pour
les
autres que d'en prendre deux parce que
vous aussi ce qu'elle va les prendre
aussi merci pour la part de vous
quel est le fou et j'ai pas bonne case
pour l'instant
des cinq
je sais pas je pense en fait j'ai
l'impression que
que
je ne peux pas jouer ça mais j'ai
l'impression que vraiment si
les Noirs jouent enfin refuse d'âme et
ben ça va quand même faire briser les
blancs qui pourront rapidement
que mal placé que le fou qui qui enfermé
en fuite donc je pense que les Nord ont
intérêt quand même de venir manger en
deux
j'ai retrouvé le dont là le fichier que
j'avais fait mercredi il y a une dizaine
de jours stouf et Carlson c'est vraiment
un spécial c'est pas une surprise de
Carlson
voilà dans la base j'étais j'étais
vérifié il avait joué du monde non
c'est du grand tout à fait
il y a un moment maintenant et il le
joue très très régulièrement et d'autres
joueurs s'ils sont mis on retrouve
Nakamura xyomi man il y a beaucoup de
joueurs qui jouent cela Tabata bye qui
est dans le challenger donc c'est une
très bonne variante c'est si c'est un
petit peu marginal et sur ce coup on
peut faire F3 comme D3 chacun a ses
avantages
mais on a encore dans des dans des
grandes parties voilà donc
oui par rapport aux autres coups oui
légèrement
cavalier F6 c'était plus joué que que
c'est 6 d'accord
c'est vraiment le grand coup mais sur
quoi
c'est si c'est peut-être un petit peu
meilleur par contre des fois ça peut
être marginal mais c'est si c'est et
très solide pour la case des 5 cavalier
et comme ça j'ai la petite la petite
théorie mais cette partie m'intéresse
théoriquement parce que comme j'ai
regardé cavalier des trois récemment
c'est tellement bizarre cavalier 3 au
quatrième coup on a envie de voir ce que
vaut cette ligne
d'accord
qu'il réfléchisse parce que on a
vraiment envie de jouer cavalier
cavalier F6 ça paraît tellement normal
on va voir
salut François bien concentré oui et
très bien concentré j'ai pas encore reçu
ton message
généralement une petite photo
tous les jours sur WhatsApp
donc F3 ouais donc là on va voir cavaler
ici on peut aussi peut-être envisager
cavalier 5
mais c'est un peu moins dans l'intérêt
de la police je pense qu'il est non plus
une position
D4 mais ça permet peut-être ça valait
aussi quoi c'est bizarre
après dans ce que j'avais regardé à
titre perso je préférais jouer la même
le même type de position sauf mais sans
l'échange des dames donc dame 7 c'est
parce que Carlsen c'est un joueur très
technique il adore jouer pour le petit
plus alors qu'à titre perso j'aurais
préféré jouer pour mon cavalier F4 et
Rocket rapidement pour un jour faire
cavalier H5 comme va chez La Grave
[Musique]
nous l'avait nous l'avait proposé quoi
ça y est j'ai reçu le message de
François
j'aurais envie de le montrer au chat
mais je pense pas que ça je pense pas
que
[Rires]
ça va très bien et toi Néandertal est-ce
que tout va bien pour toi est-ce que tu
vas mettre quelques petits pics
aujourd'hui ou non est-ce que tu es
inspiré
que la coupe de Magnus qu'on a pas trop
parlé de la coupe de Magnus mais ça
reste
c'est
dans la même idée quand même la petite
mèche alors
et c'est pas ouf voilà des cadres
cavaliers f6d4 on a le droit lune que
les deux joueurs connaissent je pense
[Musique]
Parker
pour l'instant il y a rien de neuf vous
voyez d'ailleurs les temps qui
s'affichent
et du coup il est certain que maintenu
c'est bien préparé dans cette ouverture
qui doit considérer que c'est un petit
avantage sur long terme ce qu'on appelle
une position à deux résultats et Pierre
Richard rapporte ça reste un joueur
assez fantasme donc il amène sur un
terrain technique mais on peut dire
quand même que Richard rapporte il reste
quand même assez universel il peut
toujours les joueurs de ce niveau là bon
c'est c'est cool
peut-être pas le métal que car la scène
va travailler pour prochainement pour
petrolane etc il avait travaillé pour
G-Star une marque de vêtements un moment
c'était l'égérie plus ou moins et là il
va peut-être travailler pour pétrole ou
Garnier quelque chose comme ça voilà
en tout cas ils sont un peu on peut
imaginer je pense
et un petit plan du style food étroit
roi F2 et pète C4 avec un léger avantage
espace quand même
à titre perso j'ai du mal à comprendre
comment on peut jouer ça avec les Blancs
donc comment on va on va jouer la suite
de la partie j'avoue que j'avais pas
trop investiguer ce champ là et du coup
je suis assez
j'attends avec impatience la suite parce
que c'est très plat si vous voulez pour
moi et je vois pas comment on peut en
retirer un énorme bénéfice contre un
joueur de cette tremplin et on sait que
Manu s'il veut gagner il joue pas pour
faire mieux avec les blancs très
clairement donc ça m'intéresse tout de
voir comment techniquement on fait pour
pour avancer dans ces positions là ok je
comprends qu'il faut peut-être balancer
les pions à l'elda mais ça me paraît un
peu l'aige moi aussi je j'ai
l'impression que des sac
il se passe pas grand chose
donc bon on va voir en tout cas
on va voir ce qui va nous faire un petit
Magnus
Kevin
en fait on empêche de manière très
pragmatique le coût logique de sortie de
dames
déjà donc ça fait partie du pressing et
ce qu'on pourrait jouer après E6 dans de
bonnes conditions bien sûr je vais pas
jouer G6
j'affaiblis mon roi en tout cas ça donne
pas trop envie
du coup donc on voit des perspectives la
question c'est le traitement de fu G6
qui paraît assez logique je trouve dans
ce genre de position est-ce que j'aurais
foutrangé suivi de E6 c'est peut-être ça
l'astuce
une structure
[Musique]
ça serait pénible quand même ça serait
ça serait assez moche c'est deux ici
grosses pression pas très beau et du
coup F5 c'est embêtant je tasse fixe en
fait je trouve que c'est un petit coup
mais
j'empêche de jouer puis je vais faire
des plus tard peut-être j'ai 4 aussi
ok intéressant pour ton petit Paris
d'ailleurs oui mais nul doute que
tout va trouver une parade pour
t'empêcher de gagner dans Paris
il y avait aussi dames on pouvait sans
doute prendre un F3 c'est ça
parce que si je fais ça sans sans
j'ai peut-être du G6 du coup
en plus d'un point est impossible parce
qu'à ton jeu
directement bon
tu as raison rapporte il est connu
plutôt pour le côté son côté fantasque
après il s'est quand même joué les
positions plates et c'est lui qui a joué
d'ailleurs la pétrole
il a pas trop le choix de toute façon à
son niveau à 27,50 fois de joueurs
universel mais c'est vrai que c'est un
des joueurs qui peut vraiment tout
envoyer on la cité d'ailleurs dans la
quand on parlait hier du début jojoba
c'est un des joueurs réguliers aussi de
ce genre de début un peu un peu fou
est-ce qu'il y a un coup comme un F3
c'est
j'aime pas du tout pour les cases
blanches mais c'est bien que j'aime bien
garder mes bras
problèmes je pense c'est une très très
belle idée
et d'un F5 il y a roi schisme
malheureusement pour moi que j'ai raté
après et là
je vais suer
4 c'est pas si simple
mais même ça va peut-être mais j'ai 6
on s'en sort
quand même un G4
super
c'était pour la récupérer dans la foulée
et avoir un cavalier contre un fou
et lui contre lui pour avoir lui contre
lui et me dire que bon bah peut-être que
je ressemble plus tard avec des quatre
ça n'arrête de rien ces questions sauf
mais c'est hyper intéressant ce qu'on
dit là parce que l'échange fou cavalier
aux échecs est hyper important à
maîtriser et même le thème de l'échange
en règle générale il y a beaucoup
d'erreurs qui sont faits sur cet élément
là
le cas classique c'est le cas d'un
simple échange déjà il y en a qui font
mal la conversion qui font mal le jeu du
marchand parce qu'il se trompe sur
l'évaluation d'une faible pièce d'une
forte pièce ils échangent leur forte
pièce contre les faibles pièces adverses
ça arrive et là c'était assez rigolo
parce que c'est un exemple un peu plus
un peu plus élaboré où il y aurait un
double échange de pièces donc le foie
Shang le donnait qu'on ne le cavalier F3
c'est un peu embêtant mais ce que vous
voulez derrière faire fouger 5 donc
c'est il y avait vraiment une petite
idée cachée maintenant ça marche assez
assez mal comme on l'a dit parce qu'il y
a des tactiques sur achète c'est
important de
bien regarder ce genre d'histoire ça
change une position si vous voulez
et puis on peut si vous repérez aussi
une mauvaise pièce chez l'adversaire et
ben essayer je mets toutes les pièces
sauf celle-là en fait bon dans cette
position le fouet F1 c'est pas une
mauvaise pièce mais c'est un exemple
quoi
l'impression à titre perso tout en tout
cas je ressentais pas l'avantage blanc
vous voyez que la jauge c'est un peu en
faveur des blancs vous savez on a 7
jours donc c'est difficile de l'ignorer
mais il faut F5 je trouve que c'est bien
pour
pour poser des problèmes et peut-être
faire grossir davantage
alors est-ce qu'on a d'autres parties il
y a eu fou F5 je pars juste pour revenir
ici et du coup trois serait mon coup
parce que bien sûr j'aime bien essayer
de garder des pièces
j'ai le droit ou pas
je prends les pions et j'y vais
si je prends là
mais après est-ce que je peux avoir un
avantage de développement mais bon ça a
pas l'air non mais ça paraît pas
colossal quoi après je vais faire ça tu
vas faire ça forcer
S
[Musique]
3 finalement
il faut qu'il rentre à la maison et j'ai
je pense qu'on a fait sur foot français
2 cavalier C3 il va falloir qu'on soit
en soit meilleur que ça parce que tu me
lâches toujours pas d'un français de
on peut jouer peut-être Hashi soit dans
cette position
pour pour avoir le fond à chatte et ça
serait quand même une vraiment une
meilleure nouvelle quoi même du G5 qui
est possible
d'essayer de capitaliser sur le fait que
j'avais déjà pris un pion et même à
chaque je pense que ce qui me permet de
mettre mon fond F5
je pense que c'est une position
incertaine
de stouf tout à l'heure et lui rendre
le côté beau jeu
invisiblement j'ai pas le droit ça
aurait été bien parce que le roi F2 il
donne envie de se taper un petit peu
que je me disais que j'avais toujours
les fous aussi sauf qu'il pouvait me
sauver une fois que le cavalier a part
ça va te faire cavaler des cinq je crois
que je suis fou je crois que je suis fou
Kévin mais j'ai envie de faire cavaler
des cinq
donc je vous rappelle qu'on travaille
sans jaune ici avec Kevin on la voit là
pardon avec un jour je me sens en ligne
et que les cinq salariale
ce qui va tout en bas on va on va le
laisser arriver quand même avant
on va la laisser arriver à jauge alors
ce que j'ai vu je te montre ce que j'ai
vu après
pour moi non
on va regarder on va regarder
en fait non mais je peux prendre je
pense que je peux prendre parce que tu
as pas encore
alors
qui
dame de
j'ai des 5 maintenant à tout moment
en fait et voilà je vous ai rassemble
encore en bas mais
que j'avais la même avec échec et il y
avait tout en prise et ok bon c'est un
coup que j'aurais peut-être fait sortir
comme pour rigoler parce que vous savez
qu'on bah on joue pour ça
bien
[Musique]
parce que je suis comme ça des fois je
peux pas m'empêcher de regarder des
trucs comme ça et mais j'aurais pas fait
c'est pas bon
si je calcule la ligne il y a moyen que
je le fasse quand même parce que je suis
comme ça
c'est rigolo le coup en tant que tel est
vraiment plutôt sympa
après peluche manger et faire ces quatre
et puis la partie
c'est quand même une position
[Musique]
assez égalisante quoi alors le C4
bon ça donne un pion pardon
plus tu parlais de ton G5 sauf mais il
prend tout son sens dans ce genre de
position il y a toutes les changes
d'armes tout simplement
cette position encore on est proche de
l'égalité mais j'ai pas besoin de me
corrompre et que j'ai 5
on va voir si je vous faut
être marrant
ok alors il se passe pas grand chose
ok donc là maintenant
pour la jouer donc je pense que
maintenant on va avoir d'enfant et de
jouer
assez logique parce qu'on a vu les
thématiques maintenant très forte il a
pas voulu donner son pion C2
parce qu'en fait c'est la position
vraiment
on va dire si on regarde la dame comme
ça il faudra voir etc
et avoir l'avance de l'Autrement et
voilà un peu l'initiative quoi donc ici
les Noirs je pense que doivent manger et
peut-être même jouer à 5 derrière comme
tu as proposé qui est intéressant
et certains joueurs amateurs d'ailleurs
ils comprennent pas quand vous
développez vos pièces c'est bien
normalement de les développer loin dans
le camp et demi mais essayez de faire
attention de mettre la pression à
l'adversaire et qu'au final aussi votre
pièce ne soit pas exposée dans le camp
adverse voilà des fois il y a une petite
confusion par rapport à ça vous avez
l'impression vous êtes contents vous
sortez la pièce dans le camp adverse
mais vous la faites chasser et le
revient au bercail et en plus vous avez
aidé l'adversaire à se développer donc
c'est pas c'est pas ce qu'on veut
classique j'ai envie de dire
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre est-ce
qu'on va maintenant qu'on a cette partie
un petit peu plate chez Magnus est-ce
qu'on va aller voir d'autres choses
on s'est arrêté à trois fois à 6 on
avait eu je vais vous mettre la petite
caméra sur caméra
je vais vous changer ça hop
donc du coup il y avait eu
il y avait eu X6 puis là on a eu E4
avait proposé l'idée de base de cette
structure dans le Reiki en règle
générale
on vise un petit peu la case des trois
donc elle va les prendre
il faut F4 je vais très vite
je vois très vite alors du coup
il veut le centre
qui commence à
montrer des velléités avec l'idée de 5
d'accord
si facile à jouer pour
pour les Noirs il faut trouver quelque
chose après
on sentait que F4 ne marche pas mais fou
F4 c'est très joli
le roi est un peu ouvert mais vous voyez
que les Noirs dans zéro pour au centre
et j'ai le 5 qui va arriver avec une
découverte sur un cavalier sur la tour
et les chances de dames va être
quasiment impossible à gérer
blanc c'est très dur de garder les dames
et attaquer le roi blanc en plus
peut-être
pour aller manger des pions
tu vois et
là j'aime beaucoup les blancs
qu'on voit sa posture on peut s'imaginer
que c'est encore le matin
mais
il fait la sieste
il a réussi son ouverture Vincent Kemer
j'étais assez dubitatif par rapport à ce
choix
peu conventionnel maintenant il a obtenu
ce qu'il voulait une petite position
assez plate où il a une meilleure
ossature centrale dans ce début et c'est
vraiment intéressant quoi
je pense que c'est son
ah oui d'accord je parle à Ding je pense
que c'est son réveil qui n'a pas sonné
blanc
donc
on trouve un coup pour les noirs
pas très agréable est-ce qu'un coup
je te préviens
[Musique]
ça va te faire plaisir ok je vérifie
avant de faire une bêtise mais
ça me ferait pas plaisir ça
non j'ai pas envie de le dire mon coup
c'est pas c'est vraiment pas bien en
fait
vraiment vraiment pas l'air bien
je peux venir ici venir ici
et j'ai toujours en mode sourd qui
défend mais bon
nous montre d'ailleurs le problème et la
menace de Vincent Kemer qui vient de
sortir sa pire pièce Le foussen avec ce
f-4-5 et l'activation du Fou G2 active
je pense qu'il a ripé je pense qu'il a
repeading et Will fatal D7
presque ton coup
Dame des six et sur ta Maca du coup
si je fais faut prendre 5 suivi de F4
c'est 5 échec c'est ça
échec je pense que c'est ça
semi-pointes
de position des coups du style H5 Kevin
pas terrible
H5 c'est
c'est un coup important dans cette
pollution quand on contrôle la case
noire enfin la dégrador ici pour faire
carré G4 parce qu'il ajusterait avec un
petit tour à D8 peut-être d'abord
histoire de le faire gratuitement et
après effectivement les H5 cavaliers G4
les rentrés de Tours en 3e rangée etc
en fait avec l'histoire de
la menace cavalier G4 peut-être
il y a encore ça mais je sens c'est ça
qui me fait peur
et je dois quitter la diagonale
donc
il est en difficulté digne parce que
j'ai par exemple dame prend des 6 tout
simplement stouf
puis on prend parce que
il y aura pion prend quoi du coup donc
cette position elle est plus agréable
pour pour les blancs déjà rien que celle
là ça c'est un premier avantage
mais on va chercher mieux encore mais
déjà rien que cette position digne il a
dû se décider sur quelque chose
en fait normalement Vincent Kemer il a
peu de chance de perdre cette partie un
souffle déjà
et là on pensait je pense à vous trois
donc déjà quatre qui pose problème au
fou mais il y a aussi
des faux français 3 du cabas qui est
possible il faut faire attention
[Musique]
pour activer la pièce qui ne joue pas
les gars que c'est plus sympa mais sur
ça j'ai peut-être même des idées des
fois de manger là changer un peu la
structure
5 et du coup c'est quand même
appréciable de dominer le cavalier F6
mais je suis même pas obligé de sans
doute de manger en désiste mais même ça
c'est intéressant Vincent camer va
peut-être prendre un petit peu de temps
en tout parce que il a pas mal de choix
intéressant
ce que je peux jouer ça peut-être c'est
très intéressant
bon je changerai quand même pas mon fou
toujours pareil
quelque chose comme ça
ou F3 en fait j'ai un coup tout simple
af3d5 tu disais sauf que je pense alors
[Musique]
maintenant
parce qu'on conserve les idées comme
damaca tour ADN qui sont très
intéressantes donc là on a deux
philosophies qui qui s'affrontent
souffle le cou concret pour essayer de
prendre l'initiative ou le coup un peu
statique où on veut jouer sur le long
terme pour faire mal à l'adversaire mais
en le torturant donc c'est vraiment pas
évident à la place de Vincent Kemer je
comprendrais qu'il prenne du temps dans
cette position pour évaluer les deux il
a il a deux choix très intéressant qui
ne se ressemblent pas et je sais qu'à
titre perso c'est des positions je perds
beaucoup de temps je souffre quand je
vois qu'il y a deux bons coups mais il
faut faire le choix et c'est dur quoi
c'est dur
après peut-être que contre un genre
comme Ding vu qu'il est plus fort etc il
est à deux défaites d'affilée Kemer
peut-être qu'il va prendre la finale
c'est qu'il peut pas la perdre il peut
faire un petit forcing peut-être plutôt
d'un prends des 6 tu vois dans ce type
de situation et là c'est pas sûr là
c'est pas sûr dans ma carte B7 tu auras
des 1 bon faut déjà trouver une casse
pour la dame
mais bon
en tout cas bon Vincent Kemer il a quand
même compte il a bien réussi et je crois
que c'est un animaux ce qu'on peut se
permettre la prise en F4 moi ça va pas
trop
[Musique]
et ces 14 je sais pas
honnêtement les deux coups les deux
Combes vont bien et je sais par avance
que j'aurais été très gêné il faut
prendre
je peux faire je prends j'ai gagné non
que j'avais imaginé moi sauf absolument
m'embrouiller encore je sais pas
l'embrouille
H3 ouais mais attends H3 F2 peut-être
une embrouille
tu sais j'ai eu peur mais en fait il y a
rien
que tu peux pas me forcer à prendre et
si tu me forces à prendre tu mettes à
manger 3 ce qui est pas pareil
ouf
mais j'ai vu après peut-être encore
et il y avait aussi F3 dans cette
position et c'est bien de de comparer
les petits coups
c'est pas facile de faire ses choix
évidemment
c'est chaud
très intéressant
mais
[Musique]
on a clairement pas Dame des trois oui
dame 2 on avait je crois dame de c'est
peut-être plus sérieux
il a joué dans ma carte donc
ok donc dame prend des sites donc on
voit que merde de toute façon il arrive
à
je pense qu'en début de partie il était
effectivement un peu stressé mais une
fois que la partie est lancée qu'un
joueur comme ça à l'avantage à
l'avantage ça sécurise en fait vraiment
beaucoup les choses et du coup là il va
il va jouer les cookies s'imposent donc
ici fou B7 me paraît normal sauf tout
radin et où je mets la dame
ça la grande question
alors
ça ça
quelque chose du four
pas mal ce couple
[Musique]
si ça ça me plaît plus c'est mieux c'est
ouf parce que j'avais pas envie de
mettre en dessin du coup mais ça c'est
5 peut-être pour essayer de rester actif
mais là je perds le contrôle de la case
de la case D7 et ça c'est dramatique
dans le très très avantageuse maintenant
je vais faire ça
donc je pense qu'un Kemer il n'excuse
pas l'échange de dames mais il estime
que son jeu de pièces lui permet
d'obtenir plus et il voudrait il va bien
vouloir échanger les dames mais faire
payer un peu plus l'adversaire
j'ai l'impression que l'avantage
de caméra a commencé un peu à faire
croître
[Musique]
ne pas subir ton
il a réussi à le parer comme ça que tu
avais raison donc du coup il y a eu H5
il sait que dans la finale ben il a
quand même un plus avec ça
quand même
du G5 et
une idée à la stuff c'est Grand Roc
et c'est ce qu'il est non
[Rires]
j'ai vu après pour forcer l'échange
d'âme c'est un peu du délire mais c'est
un peu compliqué
vous voyez cette
la pétrole normalement c'est ultra
solide mais là ça devient complètement
créatif alors que pourtant le choix de
Carlsen c'est la MK et D3 dame 2 donc
plutôt plan-plan mais les joueurs
derrière une position aux échecs
d'apparence peut s'exciter et là
typiquement on aurait l'exemple avec ses
cavaliers à 6 à 5 on commence à être
dans des bizarres
très intéressant alors là Magnus peut
jouer aussi à trois à trois coups de
contrôle de la casse B4 par là voilà et
on a réussi à mieux mettre le cavalier
parce que le cavalier A6 des menace
d'aller en B4 où on sait cette aussi
pour venir s'échanger contre le cavalier
F4 voilà ça serait un moyen de museler
un petit peu les blancs pour un meilleur
jeu de pièces
on passe par a6 pour aller sur une
meilleure case comme C7 par exemple pour
venir sur le site on a dit pour changer
le cavalier ou alors même pour un jour
même
à tous ce qui arrive
très très intéressante une partie un peu
qu'on a annoncé pénible les deux joueurs
laissent l'attention d'un modo d'un mot
c'est un aucun décan ne veut développer
l'adversaire c'est normal
donc il y a une véritable tension en a
le même cas dans les dans les cas de
tension de structure de pions quand on
sait qu'il ne faut pas prendre on n'y va
pas mais c'est très très pénible des
fois de subir la pression
est-ce qu'il y a des parties il y avait
erguezi à Moussa torov très intéressant
[Musique]
est-ce que l'idée serait pas d'essayer
de me faire froid un jour
maybe mais c'est ça paraît pas très
conventionnel
S
est-ce que je peux
proposer des idées à stuff maintenant
alors du coup
je commence à avoir des idées j'ai
quatre H4
voilà je fais ma journée la journée du
stuffer j'ai fait des paris à la soupe
et des coups à la soupe maintenant je
sais comment ça se passe maintenant tu
vois du coup c'est à moi d'être plus
solide aujourd'hui ok
donc c'est un peu mais sinon j'aimerais
bien le sécuriser B2 et après on voyait
envoyer ça parce que peut-être que c'est
B2 le problème
c'est 2
et du coup c'est embêtant
l'idée est très sympa mais il faut que
je sécurise
du coup
trop bien du sens B3 en B1 on peut la
mettre là c'est vrai que descendre les
pions avec des pions ça a du sens que
sur des cartes on peut jouer C4 un jour
ça peut aussi avoir du sens pour en fait
bloquer on va dire ce petit pion isolé
tu vois ici donc c'est aussi une idée
peut-être sur le long terme donc
peut-être plutôt trop bien que B3 je
sais pas
si tu me fais dans ma 5 faut encore que
je défende à deux
c'est pas évident
c'est pas trop mal parce que
c'est un peu énervant à traiter après je
peux peut-être jouer tour B1 et sur
Damas 5 cette fois-ci je joue mon plan
d'attaque parce que tu as juste bouffer
à deux c'est long
donc
il était mal placé moi pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas donc là il y aurait
peut-être Damas 4
ouais tu vas où
c'est pour contrôler la carte C4 et
peut-être faire te proposer un mandat C4
du coup sur ça je peux plus faire ça je
crois
je peux faire
j'imagine Kevin les coups comme roi 2
tours géant G4 tu sais
elle a eu à la Youssoupha
qui est possible
n'est pas pris de drogue c'est juste que
ce tout fait très inspirant à chaque à
chaque streaming balance des choses et
finalement dans ma jeunesse jusqu'à mes
18 ans je jouais quand aux échecs
vraiment de manière hyper agressive et
après je me suis calmé du coup bah là
c'est la seconde jeunesse et de temps en
temps je fais encore des petits
craquages dans mes parties une partie
sur 10 on va dire où j'envoie toutes les
pièces
j'ai fait une partie d'ailleurs très
très marrante au dernier Top 16 j'ai
joué Vianney Domenech un joueur a
quasiment 2300 et on a fait vraiment une
partie de dingue j'étais complètement
foutu d'ailleurs dans la partie mais
j'ai réussi à le à l'arnaquer un peu
dans les complications voilà et du coup
mais j'étais quasiment maths sur
l'échiquier
c'était j'avais un roi assez bancal un
roi qui avait fait une sorte de petite
cabane sauf mais je peux te dire que ça
avait mal tourné la cabane c'était fait
un peu déglingué
et
un peu de Souf tous les jours pour
garder votre âme d'enfant recommandé par
tous les praticiens voilà c'est à peu
près ça l'approche de la crise de la
quarantaine pour Néandertal ça peut être
ça aussi
déjà
terrible tu as quel âge Kevin
j'ai 37 37
on dirait pas comme ça mais c'est vrai
là j'ai d'habitude je mens de 10 ans et
ça se passe bien et là j'avais envie de
te dire la vérité voilà
donc ça passe vite ça passe vite ça
passe vite
on est tout le temps dans le jeu et toi
Steph moi j'ai 24 ans
[Rires]
pourquoi
donc Kevin à 47 ans pas mal bien joué en
tout cas la grosse pizza je me suis pris
un pack digne de Neandertal mais la
grosse pizza pas mal pas mal très bon en
maths la grosse pizza
pas mal
du coup
de 90
forest
Erie c'est juste le
waouh il y a eu un thème hyper
intéressant de Jordan van forest
autant le E5 tu l'avais annoncé très
vite stouf c'est du grand classique il y
a eu un truc vraiment hyper marrant
après
là c'est vraiment incroyable ouais alors
tu sais que j'y ai pensé tout à l'heure
ce terme-là en plus pour faire mes
donc si vous voulez alors que les Blancs
se dirigent tranquillement vers une
attaque de l'aile dame les noirs
viennent de claquer un pion pour fixer
la pousser la poussée B4 et mettre une
pression sur B2
mais après j'aurais quand même toujours
en cavalier bouger un B4 voilà c'est ça
c'est ça qui m'interpelle stouf
peut-être que ce thème est classique
mais quand même
on a dans la position des cavaliers B6
qui a essayé 4 à un moment mais bon
c'est bizarre il y a eu 50 à tenir donc
comment ça va le jouer après ok
parce que du coup il y a un clouage bien
sûr moyenne à réguler déjà donc va
falloir faire un CAP d'abord
ouais je sais pas comment ça joue
j'aurais bien qu'est-ce qui se passe sur
cavalier A2 concrètement à peut-être
pris ce D4 et j'ai des problèmes sur mon
roi quand même faut que je fasse
attention
[Musique]
pour m'enlever du vis-à-vis et du coup
on pêchait les toutes les
idées de cavalier B6
et voir ce qui se passe
que dès que j'enlève mon carrelier ces
trois il y a plus qu'à éb6 à cause de
vous prend à 5
ou peut-être cavalier D1 pour pouvoir
bétonner la case E3
sens pour B4 mais tu vois j'ai peur de
me faire contrer au centre avec eux
prendre des cartes un moment sauf que je
peux pas reprendre du cavalier
le roi s'ouvre beaucoup au centre un an
de rater quelque chose terrible
et chaud en tout cas la position que
vous voyez j'ai envie de faire fou aux
deux petits rocs et ça y est j'aurais
presque gagné la partie
en tout cas j'aurais bien aimé
gérer la problématique
après
là on se précipite sur
sur un coup de cavalier mais on pouvait
peut-être directement jouer aux deux
pour aller Rocket rapidement j'ai une
idée en fait mais je me dis que
peut-être que là il y a un coup qu'on a
pas du tout à l'heure
oui c'est pour ça que je voulais jouer
béca très rapidement alors je sais pas
si je vais manger là d'abord peut-être
manger
[Musique]
mais du coup ça marche pas oui c'est ça
c'est ça
c'était encore plus facile on avait ce
BK tout le temps c'est pour ça que j'ai
envie de faire B4 à cause de fou ces
deux qui me fait un peu peur
c'est peut-être pas trop grave mais il
faut c'est de ça ça a l'air menacent non
c'est une position très compliquée mais
du coup un cavalier B6 est-ce que c'est
vraiment si tu prends là en fait salut
Arnaud salut et puis Mélide salut tonton
aide salut à tous ceux qui arrivent et
qu'on ne voit pas
salut à tous
nul entre les voies et Aniche c'est vrai
et oui c'est vrai super merci c'est 14
ouais bon de toute façon on l'avait on
avait dit que ça on pensait que ça
allait pas jouer énormément
tranquille
le choix d'ouvertures
on peut même se demander si les joueurs
ont
vraiment essayé quelque chose
ça fait ça fait une nul à très très
tranquille des deux joueurs un peu trop
tranquille
à notre goût mais après on peut pas les
blâmer ils jouent très souvent
très souvent ensemble mais ça paraît pas
ça paraît pas être un énorme combat
cette partie avec un choix timide
d'ouverture et derrière une partie
timide des deux joueurs après
globalement je peux vous dire que dans
ce type de tournoi des fois on voit
beaucoup de nuls de ce style là et on
est plutôt gâté depuis le début du
tournoi particulièrement hier j'ai cru
que le niveau de jeu était assez
exceptionnel
mais parti et non pas duré très
longtemps mais le niveau de jeu était
assez incroyable là on est parti sur des
bonnes bases aussi j'ai l'impression
tiens c'est 14 il y a pas une règle où
ils doivent jouer au moins 30 coups il
me semble que voyons leur en voyant leur
feuille j'ai cru que c'était comme ils
ont fait nul au 21e j'ai cru que c'était
20 ou du coup la
je vais regarder si Kevin j'ai un coup
pour toi
à proposer dans cette position
mais tu as pas aimé mais bon
[Rires]
on reste dans le thème tu vois avant de
Forest il a joué contre McDo il y a
quelques jours et il y avait c'était une
une envie d'un max accepté il y avait eu
un centre de pions monstrueux pour les
blancs et j'ai envie de penser à cavaler
vs 5 aussi parce qu'on garde un peu le
centre je menace aussi de faire B4 et je
me dis que scorpion prend puis on prend
en fait la courbe elle est pas si non
mais je trouve ce genre de gars
mais oui c'est elle est tripante la
position il y a énormément de ressources
pour les deux joueurs elle va être folle
cette partie
qui est très positionnel mais qui est
capable de calculer aussi hyper hyper
bien je me souviens alors du stage donc
c'était il y a très longtemps maintenant
mais il faisait les
études à l'aveugle
et il avait plus vite que moi qui voyait
non mais j'ai envie de dire bien sûr
parce que ces joueurs là en fait ça leur
change quasiment rien d'être à l'aveugle
c'est comme si vous le faisiez tous les
deux sur l'échiquier et du coup bah le
petit mot il va il va plus vite en plus
Prague bon voilà on savait que ça va
être futur 2007 plus
du coup c'est des piles électriques en
termes de calcul
d'ailleurs tous les joueurs ils
pourraient je pense là nous mettre à la
mangue à l'amande en étant à l'aveugle
je sais pas même en termes de cadence tu
vois
pour qu'elle serait
la cadence qu'on leur donnerait pour
équilibrer une partie contre nous tu
vois
c'est à dire nous on a 1h30 combien ils
ont par exemple de leur côté pour que ça
soit équilibré que c'est 5 + 1 c'est 3 +
1 c'est je sais pas mais c'est
monstrueux en fait on se rend pas compte
le niveau des joueurs tellement il est
tellement il est il est élevé par
rapport aux autres
oui et je dirais surtout dans le
on est capable de bien jouer mais il
nous faut du temps tu vois par rapport à
ces joueurs là ou même qu'on a vu le
speechess en 1 + 1 tu vois c'est des
parties de dingue quoi des fois alors
des fois on a plus ça effectivement il y
a une connerie parce que ça peut arriver
vite mais objectivement
les mecs jouent à un niveau des fois en
3 + 5 c'est juste
presque parfait quoi donc c'est quand
même là la grosse différence je sais que
sous pression du temps je suis plus le
même moi je fais je fais beaucoup plus
[Musique]
pas du tout parce qu'en fait il y a un
problème c'est que en faisant ça non
qui va tomber c'est ça et même peut-être
cavalier prend avec des échecs je sais
pas si je fais [ __ ] logique mais on
prend un casier G4 j'ai au moins ça d'un
bout j'ai cavaler et après la présence
au pion ici donc pour manger le 5 mais
comme le comme je dis Kevin qui est
intéressant aussi il y a un petit peu
pour les pièces mais
ça fait beaucoup
c'est un peu le hasard mais en tout cas
bon il y aurait beaucoup de pièces et là
la dame vaut pas trois pièces mineures
très clairement c'est une galère de
jouer ses positions
c'est très mal
ça c'est très joli par contre vous
pouvez regarder il y avait une sorte de
supermarché on prend tout ce qui passe
et on donne notre Dame
il faudra leur interdire de réfléchir
souvent 1h30 aussi bah ouais non mais en
fait
mais à l'époque à l'époque alors je sais
plus c'était il y a combien de temps
c'était quand même il y a quand même
beaucoup beaucoup d'années et ben on
avait
on avait c'était mvl qui jouait contre
contre Baki en blitz et en fait et ben
il se prenait il se prenait je crois
trois contre deux
en fait enfin juste
même en blitz en fait s'ils sont en but
c'est que normalement ça va permettre
dur pour nous
mais je sais pas
je sais pas comment dire essayer
d'ajuster un petit peu les temps mais
en fait juste les joueurs sont beaucoup
plus reconnus
j'aime beaucoup les blancs
pour calculer donc c'est toujours
difficile de parler de handicap de temps
quand il y a trop un gros écart de
niveau et c'est pas faux c'est pas faux
effectivement il y a cette dimension là
ça dépendra aussi de la presta donc faut
deux jouets ouais c'est normal
urgence
et après voir ce qui se passe donc il
laisse cavaler B6
on peut faire cavalier prend E5 donc du
coup il faut gérer déjà le la
problématique qu'est-ce qu'on fait ed
dans ce cas là sauf
pour venir ici et je rentre juste si
j'avance développement et j'avais aussi
B3 sur cavalier B6 hein si j'avais envie
de te pas donner mais bon je peux aussi
jouer sur l'avance de développement
comme quoi
en faisant boire les pros mais c'est pas
sûr c'est pas sûr que ça marche parce
que ça dépend bon mais il y a un stade
où effectivement il y a peut-être moyen
mais
on sait très bien avec tout que ça peut
me mettre stimulant surtout pour les
cadences rapides voilà
bien joué Néandertal il nous fait une
petite un litre c'est pas assez et sur
les mineurs site interdits bravo
Néandertal qui nous ramène à la raison
dans le chat
je pense qu'on les perd très vite
la fameuse espagnole italienne
je vais mettre la caméra surprise sur
Google
et donc d'un point d'interrogation
avec les Blancs
pour l'instant il se passe pas
grand-chose
et Google qui est un peu mal au temps
comment toutes les parties qui jouent
pourquoi j'ai joué c'est pas impossible
il n'y a pas obtenu grand-chose dans
cette ouverture Google ça c'est sûr
mais c'est dur quand tu joues qu'on est
genre comme ça tu vois au niveau du
répertoire surprend un Wesley Sow c'est
c'est hyper dur donc là on voit vraiment
les jeunes qui sont malentendants en
grand bain que le contre les meilleurs
joueurs du monde ben c'est plus
difficile quand le niveau travail niveau
ouverture bien sûr
parce que
surprendre un jour à 2600 et l'autre ça
reste possible complètement mais en 2007
60 enfin tout le meilleur joueur du
monde comme comme Saw comme on a vu
aussi les carrollins etc bah ça reste ça
reste dur donc là on va vraiment savoir
une belle expérience en tout cas pour
gokash
pour après pouvoir débriefer un peu tout
ça et voir un peu tout ce qui ce qui
s'est mal passé quoi
en tout cas bon il faut quand même qu'il
fasse des résultats pour garder un
minimum de confiance mais ça sera dur à
chaque fois
tu dis n'importe quoi puisque déjà gagné
le blitz de Guingamp et pour gagner le
blitz de Guingamp il faut du coffre ou
du coffre donc non non faut regarde dans
la foire aux gap c'est juste rien que de
faire le stream et de parler en même
temps je peux te dire que ça déjà ça
m'amène à faire quelques bêtises mais
non non
comme j'ai gagné une fois le bus de
Guingamp je suis peinard à vie sur ce
côté là c'est le respect ultime gagner
le blitz de Guingamp
très très longtemps c'était il y a
c'était il y a une dizaine d'années et
c'était le fameux tournoi de Condom qui
est dans le Gers qui est assez connu
pour être assez festif quoi ouais
des amis et puis le but on devait boire
je sais plus deux ou trois verres par
partie et tu avais des cocktails qui
faisait des fameux coupées
à 9 parties il fallait boire deux verres
pas partie et donc je suis arrivé à la à
l'avant dans la partie et j'avais un
truc du genre si c'est une sur 7
[Rires]
à mon avis il est là il nous écoute
mais
du coup ouais
ça commence à faire beaucoup et là j'ai
perdu
une partie donc c'est un truc qui me
relever il y avait pas mal de titrés il
y avait d'ailleurs Paul Valentine qui
était là qui est spécialiste etc il y a
plein d'autres gens
et du coup j'avais joué un maître feed
français que je tiré le nom pour pour
l'histoire et du coup j'avais j'avais un
Benco avec les Noirs ils avaient
quatre pions plus c'est comme ça j'avais
tout mangé et la finale fin de Tours
Scipion qu'autour d'option
et mon adversaire qui n'a qui vont jouer
et puis il lui restait lui à 5 secondes
à la pendule moi il me restait 30 et
puis je joue un coup et j'ai un peu sur
la pendule et puis la pendule c'est pas
déclenché
et puis j'avais 30 secondes à la pendule
quand même
j'ai fini par perdre autant
j'ai perdu la partie j'étais pas content
parce qu'il a attendu lui il a vu que
j'ai mal appuyé enfin j'ai appuyé mais
la pendule ne sais pas déclencher tu
sais ça ça arrive des fois
et j'ai perdu la partie et donc tu vois
que j'avais bien joué pour arriver
jusque là et puis la partie j'ai elle a
gagné quoi par contre j'avais un peu du
mal à voir ce qui était autour comme par
exemple pas la pendule qui était qui
tournait chez moi et
mais après faut pas il faut pas croire
mais c'est vrai que des fois ça donne
des forces un petit peu après trop non
mais
ok il est parti lente et Blitz en partie
lente c'est sûr que ça n'aide pas en
blitz oui pour être un peu stimulé ça
peut aider parce qu'il faut jouer vite
faut être un peu excité faut essayer de
balancer sur le roi adverse et mais
c'est vrai que tu t'es fait un peu un
peu enfumé c'était pas
je pense que bon c'est de ma faute après
c'est un tournoi il y a il y avait rien
en jeu il y avait il y avait des prix
mais vraiment des prix c'est des enfin
je passe pour le pour les prix c'était
vraiment pour s'amuser
c'est ma faute 100% mais il aurait pu
dire il aurait pu
trouver ça
tu peux tu peux faire la part des choses
c'est
le côté sportif moi j'ai vu j'avais vu
dans le temps moi j'ai vu dans des Open
tu vois bon il y a un joueur qui que je
connais très bien qui est la région
niçoise
qui était spécialisé ça je l'avais
plusieurs fois je vais prendre des
enfants qui ben l'enfant en diagnostic
quoi que ce soit il est obligé et lui il
attend
il attend il attend il attend et je
trouve que c'est complètement abusé
faire ça j'aime pas du tout
tu peux dire une fois ou deux enfin
après je sais pas si ça peut arriver tu
vois généralement quand la pendule c'est
soit que tu es débutant que tu as pas
l'habitude soit que tu es stressé ou
quoi tu vois mais bon ça va quoi mais là
le fait le fait d'attendre et mettre tes
mains comme ça pour faire genre que tu
réfléchis alors qu'en fait tu as vu que
le mec il allait tomber enfin juste je
trouve ça pas cool et
donc donc voilà
c'est pas c'est pas l'idée
c'est vraiment pas l'idée bon après ça
arrive toujours
on y peut rien il y a tout à chaque fois
dans le milieu des fois c'est
très bons joueurs et d'autres pas du
tout voilà mais il faut faire la part
des choses faut rester dans les règles
et puis voilà être soi-même ce qu'on
peut dire marche bien
aux échecs enfin il faut je pourrai
faire plaisir quoi c'est pour faire un
truc comme ça juste voilà mais tant
qu'on prend du plaisir
en jouant d'échec c'est cool quoi
complètement
à gratter un truc de manière malhonnête
c'est pas du tout l'esprit mais après
bon chacun
nous ce qu'on fait en tant qu'entraîneur
qui est moi et ben on m'incule aussi aux
jeunes joueurs des comportements tu vois
c'est un peu tout ça quoi complètement
comment se comporter etc de manière de
penser de vivre aussi donc
la triste
et on a eu des histoires enfin par
exemple j'ai déjà un élève qui avait un
souci de triche il avait il avait triché
de manière avérée et on avait fait
grosse discussion avec son club avec les
parents machin ça arrive de toute façon
on est confronté maintenant sur Internet
parce que j'ai eu le même problème
et pourquoi il a accéléré un peu le
phénomène quoi donc tu vois ça va bon
voilà et en fait du coup on a fait
pareil on avait avec Romy on avait
vraiment des vœux avec les parents pour
discuter avec le gamin aussi pour parce
que c'est vrai que ben c'est dommage
pour lui quoi et puis si il commence à
le faire ici il peut même plus tard oui
c'est ça en fait ça peut ça peut
dégénérer quoi donc non mais l'idée
c'est pas le truc public ni quoi que ce
soit c'est juste tu vois en interne
régler le problème et faire en sorte que
le gamin plus tard ben il puisse
continuer à jouer d'échecs
tranquillement se faire plaisir quoi
donc voilà on essaie d'impliquer un peu
les valeurs aux enfants des fois tu en
as qui qui sont un peu plus dissipés que
d'autres ou qui ont des comportements un
peu plus difficiles que d'autres
c'est le but de sa 4 en fait
moi le but ça cache j'avais beaucoup
beaucoup joué quand j'étais plus jeune
mais
surtout en un contre un
crazy house
ça pour le coup j'avais énormément joué
sur Internet
et j'aime bien c'est génial j'en ai fait
quelques-uns sur la chaîne mais c'est
dur parce que je joue avec le chat donc
c'est des gens qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude du blizzakat et surface.com
il y en a qui font qui en font pas mal à
souffler c'est pas facile le niveau il
est arrivé mais tu sais que moi moi
j'avais j'avais travaillé le Crazy House
et pour te dire en fait à un moment
donné j'étais
mille fois meilleur en crise d'échec et
j'étais à quasiment 2300 hellofid quand
même mais par exemple je suis en
d'autres sites un site qui maintenant
plus c'était quand j'étais jeune c'était
bio 21 et j'étais numéro 2 du site
pendant très longtemps et même sur les
chaises que j'avais jeux pendant aussi
bon c'était longtemps c'était donné
entre 10 donc top 10 j'avais 2800 hello
et bon maintenant je sais plus jouer
enfin
très longtemps
ouais mais j'avais travaillé la théorie
et tout je connaissais plein de choses
et c'était hyper intéressant et
maintenant bah ok je pense que si je
rejoue ça va tu vois mais j'ai tout
perdu je sais plus les ouvertures déjà
j'ai oublié
même les on appelle ça quatre pour ceux
qui cherchent voilà
mais en burger sinon un burger si bon
que ça parce qu'en fait on peut aussi
déjà la théorie tu en as l'impression
que c'est le même jeu en fait c'est pas
le même jeu entre le burger c'est le
casse ben si tu veux c'est pas c'est pas
la même les mêmes
théorie enfin toutes les différents
parce qu'il y en a un en fait quand
c'est réserve effectivement d'une pièce
à l'adversaire et en fait et ben tu la
récupères par exemple là je fais je fais
cavaler prendre le 5 et ben j'ai un pion
dans la main que je peux reposer vous
voyez alors qu'en Burger et ben tu es
devant ton adversaire donc en fait les
pièces que tu vas avoir besoin enfin
c'est ton adversaire qui lui va manger
les besoins adversaires et te donner tes
pièces donc en fait quand tu manges en
E5 tu as pas forcément de pions qui
arrive quoi tu vois et tu peux avoir
n'importe quoi qui arrive même rien des
fois tu peux avoir et du coup c'est
différent et du coup un burger bon moi
je j'ai un autre très très bas sur James
com on avait joué on avait joué avec
avec Fatou
et puis on est perdu dommage qu'elle
soit pas là
on avait joué donc moi j'avais un vélo
de base je sais plus peut-être à 2002 et
quelques surescom et puis on a peur on a
joué lors d'un événement il y a quelques
mois et on a dû faire genre 0 sur 10
quoi
[Rires]
le niveau était fort quoi et puis en
fait quand t'as pas l'habitude vraiment
de jouer de sa carte etc tu peux très
très vite te retrouver mal et c'est pas
facile mais après voilà moi je pense pas
que je suis un très bon joueur de
quand elle était moche comme beaucoup en
crazy house Je suis pas trop à la rue
non plus tu vois quand je vois mais en
plus quand tu fais des bugs house tu
vois mais en club quoi pour ça c'est
marrant quoi mais le niveau il est pas
ouf parce qu'on se tous ensemble etc par
contre sur Internet c'est quand même des
gens qui sont hyper entraînés j'avais
d'ailleurs une anecdote avec donc avec
Sami qui était sur le fait tout à
l'heure et ben à chaque fois qu'on
allait au tournoi de sens à Barcelone
chaque été et ben il y avait un tournoi
de début de sa 4 en fait un matin et non
je fais toujours ensemble et on l'a on
l'a gagné plusieurs fois et
bon il y a le niveau était pas un peu
très ouf donc on l'a gagné et puis une
fois j'ai j'ai fait nappe je sais pas
pourquoi il y a une année où j'avais
l'impression de de
d'avoir peint allumé le cerveau mais
c'était hallucinant que moi je faisais
n'importe mais sinon on a gagné comme je
pense deux fois et l'autre année c'était
assez marrant j'étais parti avec un
autre pote faire le tournoi et un mètre
fuite français qui a 2300 tu vois et moi
c'était l'année où vraiment j'étais à
fond dans le crânes je connaissais tout
par cœur j'étais hyper fort ça dérange
là et lui ben il avait jamais vraiment
joué mais il a 2300 donc il calcule bien
et c'est un peu il comprend le truc et
du coup on était premier vélo parce
qu'il prenait la moyenne de deux joueurs
donc moi j'avais environ 2002 et lui
2003 et donc une table 1 et du coup on
commence tables 1 donc on arrive à
moitié en retard au tournoi parce que
c'était dans une rue qu'on trouvait pas
la rue bref et en gros
ronde un on ajoute contre deux joueurs
on s'est fait complètement exploser
vraiment le mec il était fort quoi alors
que c'était la ronde 1 c'est comme ça
c'est être forfait de l'autre tu vois et
après
on a tout gagné
et eux ils avaient perdu une partie et
du coup on s'est retrouvé en finale en
fait si tu veux donc c'était un sort de
système suisse puis à la fin ils ont
voulu faire la finale entre les deux
premières équipes et donc on avait genre
but sur neuf tous les deux et donc on a
fait une dernière partie contre ceux qui
nous est battu la première ronde pour
départager et là donc moi j'avais les
Noirs toute la tout le temps j'avais
laissé les blancs mon pote à chaque fois
parce que il savait pas trop la théorie
etc donc maintenant je vais me
débrouiller
et du coup on a encore perdu mais les
mecs vraiment fort quoi genre moi le moi
j'avais une partie chaude et à côté ils
faisaient Mathieu à chaque fois mais il
était fondé mais mais sur la 2 échecs et
les mecs étaient vraiment forts et je me
dis et je me dis non mais ouais c'était
la pression et je veux tous les bons
coups et les thèmes tous les trucs et
j'ai dit vraiment les mecs sont forts
quoi alors que vous avez mis 1800 et
l'autre tous les deux quoi et après
alors Miss des prix et ben les deux gens
viennent me voir et me demande si je
suis le fameux joueur qui était sur le
site là
et en fait ils m'ont reconnu voilà et en
fait
j'étais numéro 2 du site à l'époque
c'était le site du 21 et j'avais 3100 et
3002 et eux ils étaient tous environ à
3000 quoi donc en fait qu'est-ce que tu
veux faire en fait mais c'est des mecs
en plus qui jouent beaucoup à deux en
burger moi pour le coup
en fait mais c'est marrant que tu fais
un tour en Espagne et les deux joueurs à
la fin ils disent mais attends c'est toi
lui hein
et toi tu es qui et là il me donne leur
pseudo
en fait c'était sûr que c'est pas lui
quoi tu as deux monstres en fait tu as
deux monstres
c'était un jouet mais du coup
oui mais bon mais tu voyais en plus que
ça existait la théorie jusqu'à assez
loin c'était c'était assez marrant en
fait
du coup je peux plus jamais jouer depuis
c'est
sur les échecs et du coup j'avais aussi
un petit peu au lit d'ailleurs j'avais
appris un peu un jour J parce que le
shoguy c'est à chaque japonais et en
fait ben c'est des échecs donc tu as une
tourte à un fou tu as plein de pièces
qui sont similaires tu as aussi le roi
le but c'est de faire échec et mat
comment les échecs mais en fait et ben
tu as trois rangées de promotion et tu
peux les faire que tu manges tu peux les
reposer en fait donc c'est une sorte de
[ __ ] ça 4 échec avec des pièces
différentes et c'est hyper intéressant
et du coup bah moi j'avais des facilités
au jeudi vu que j'avais beaucoup
beaucoup joué en crazy House et puis
j'avais joué une de mes premières
parties il y avait une sorte au Festival
des Jeux à Cannes
ma troisième partie de ma vie quoi et
le mec à la fin il a fait genre que
c'était une partie pédagogique quoi
quand je l'ai maté il a dit très très
bien voilà tu vois donc là j'avais fait
exprès parce que tu vois non je dis oui
c'est ça ouais le mec il était comme ça
il essaie de pas perdre
mais bon voilà donc j'étais assez
content mais c'était marrant quoi
on connaît tous les vagues dans notre
chat que personne qui nous ont demandé
si on connaissait les échecs
psychologiques
mais on connaît les échecs marseillais
la dame cachée etc il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de variantes du jeu d'échec le
Bouftou bref on peut tout citer je peux
vous dire qu'on est ouais dans dans le
jeu depuis tellement longtemps dans
cette sphère là que normalement
quasiment tous les variantes du jeu
d'échec on les a testé
il y a même un jeu tu as déjà dû jouer à
tempête sur l'échiquier le petit jeu de
cartes qu'on avait quand on était mort
je sais pas si tu te rappelles de ça
quoi
au début et puis après il est sorti en
couleur
ouais c'était marrant ça c'est des c'est
des cartes en fait tu as des cartes dans
la main et chaque coup tu peux soit
jouer un coup sur l'échiquier soit avec
une carte spéciale avec un pouvoir par
exemple tiens le cavalier comme un fou
ou tiens tu peux je peux pas les pions
plus reculer ou plein de règles comme ça
et c'est assez drôle et moi j'ai
toujours été mauvais à eux parce qu'en
fait je connaissais pas les cartes c'est
à chaque fois je devais le lire
par exemple
5000 était un jouable parce qu'en fait
il connaissait des cartes et ça va être
très bien donc dès qu'ils voyaient la
dès qu'ils voyaient la la carte qui dit
bah c'est bon j'ai ça et en fait si tu
veux moi ce genre de joueurs qui en a
besoin de des cartes parce que sinon il
peut pas inverser la tendance de la
partie quoi tu vois sauf c'est c'est
vraiment typique quoi c'est très
clairement quoi
il n'y a pas de blague marre
à tempête
et du coup les échecs marseillais c'est
je fais un coup mon adversaire en fait
deux j'en fais trois il en fait 4 et
souvent on va pas trop loin parce qu'il
y a plein de maths qui sont possibles
assez rapidement voilà et les clubs
d'échec en France les plus forts ça
dépend en jeûne c'est qu'un échec qui a
été dix fois champion de France et qui
est champion de France en titre même
cette année c'est un peu plus chaud pour
eux que d'habitude mais ils peuvent
encore l'être toutes tout n'est pas du
tout perdu
il y a des clubs comme Corbas
Marseille ça commence à à bien pousser à
bien pousser aussi il y a des souvent
des clubs de région parisienne qui sont
très forts nos bas d'échec par exemple
et chez les adultes c'est un petit peu
différent parce que là ça tourne un peu
plus les joueurs sont payés donc il y a
une dimension que les clubs à gros
budget un peu comme au foot mais dans
des proportions moindres en termes
financières mais c'est ceux qui ont les
meilleurs joueurs donc on peut citer
Asnières grand échiquier
il y a vraiment un gros noyau dur donc à
Clichy
Bischwiller voilà Bischwiller c'est le
multiple multiple champion de France il
y a
Bischwiller pour vous donner une idée
donc c'est des équipes à 8 joueurs ils
jouent avec une joueuse féminine au
généralement au huitième à stocker c'est
sans doute
c'est qui la famille de bitchwiller
enfin une féminine à 24 et un grand
maître à 2500 au 7e échiquier quoi quand
je dis 2500 c'est 2550 quoi donc c'est
souvent des équipes où il y a 7 grands
maîtres et un mètre voilà pour pour
l'échiquier féminin voilà globalement
comment ça se passe pour donner une idée
donc
les clubs qui ont les plus gros budgets
donc Bischwiller Clichy Asnières c'est
généralement les gros matchs voilà
si vous tenez à vos points et l'eau il
doit il doit faire référence au petit au
petit jeune qui qui font très mal dans
ces tournures en connaissant
mais oui il y a des tournois plus il y a
John plus
plus souvent c'est c'est dur parce
qu'ils sont en pleine progression
généralement donc il y a eu du cavalier
B4 il y a eu du roi F2 c'est très créa
et plein de choses on s'est arrêté à C4
qui a été trois qui avaient les assis il
a joué
et sur cavalier V4 et ben il y a je
t'aime bien c'est quoi je m'en fous donc
il finit par garder les dames donc je
suis assez content
au début sauf qu'il y a complètement
vrillé mais en fait personne qui voulait
pas forcément jouer la finale je pense
que c'est vrai que la Fnac est bonne
pour lui mais qu'il y avait quand même à
cœur décide de jouer la position avec
les pièces alors que rapport et ben
c'est un joueur qui
qui aime bien quand même les positions
assez
à dire assez freestyle donc comment on
fait sur A3 B4 stouf j'ai hyper peur de
ce coup-là à 3 B4 ça a l'air fort non
enfin si on commence les proposer donc
sur cavalier à deux va y avoir tour à
deux sûrement
il y a un problème dans cette position
on nous dit la journée
tout à fait
[Musique]
cette position quand même de trouver
le chemin pour embêter le roi blanc
qu'on imagine qu'il y a peut-être
quelque chose dessus ton G5 fait sens
auquel cas on pourrait jouer cavalier 2
quand même
je sais pas s'il essaie de tout casser
moi j'ai quatre c'est pas mal comme j'ai
4 fois 6 éliminer le four en train 3
en tout cas les pièces viennent sur le
roi en F2 donc peut-être parce que j'ai
du B4 quand même qui peut arriver vite
aussi
est-ce qu'on peut pas jouer tout revu de
petits coups pour la case 3 comme tu
voulais souffler le petit coup pour la
case de 3 intéressant
et sur Fougères 5 sans doute X6
G4 gagne peut-être sous avec Dame
transgess5e 3 et là
donc là ça peut
donc Magnus il doit quand même faire
gaffe à la rentrée du cavalier en C de
suite tout rude bravo Richard rapporte
quand même pour ce cette thématique là
que bien sûr
dès le départ je me dis waouh il laisse
à 3 B4 mais en fait il a prévu ksc2 tout
re 8 il a vu une attaque avec le jeu de
pièces
un peu ce qui va jouer avant de passer
parfaitement il dit je t'enlève ton
cavalier B4 et du coup je me ferai pas
avoir avec ton kfc2
elle va être folle cette partie les deux
rois
ça va être du rock opposé
on peut imaginer peut-être ça
avec un tour 1 et un BK rapidement
là il reste sans doute un plus
j'aime beaucoup la position de magnésium
et est-ce que le cavalier des trois du
coup comme il est bizarre est-ce qu'on
est obligé d'échanger
[Musique]
et plus tard il va y avoir des problèmes
peut-être du coup de dessin mais est-ce
que j'ai le droit de faire
C5 c'est bizarre
ça fait bizarre donc
où je croque ouais non j'ai pas envie de
croquer une fois du du Fou
du coup ça a pas de sens enfin après je
vais échanger derrière mais du coup
après qu'il y avait des trois j'ai
l'impression que les blancs sont mieux
mais l'ordi dit pas ça dit que c'est à
peu près égal mais comment on fait avec
les noirs pour résister dans cette
position
je suis assez
inquiet quand même pour Richard Laporte
que je trouve pas l'idée
est bizarre mais j'arrive pas si vous
voulez à trouver
un coup pour faire mal
parce que des idées cavaliers à 6 de
résidence ouais bah j'ai regardé ça
aussi on va se prendre des cartes
bientôt qu'il faut jouer à trois je sais
pas réserve mais on a l'impression
d'avoir des très en retard à la cavalier
à 6 plutôt mal placé
moi j'aime pas du tout les noirs
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai qu'il y a de belles
pièces ici c'est de beaucoup beaucoup
d'avance de développement enfin d'espace
vers de ce côté là
pour les blancs on est vraiment coincé
dans cette position même à terme
pour presque faire ces quatre pour
l'instant il y a cavalier Beckham D3
tout ça c'est pas clair mais à terme je
vais pouvoir le faire et coincé quand
même mon adversaire
qui pose problème du coup peut-être un
petit à trois des fois ça peut être
intéressant pour essayer de faire C4 et
bloquer
et d'ailleurs dans ces positions là
après Kevin les Blancs ont rien pion
passé protégé par par C5 et donc la
défense normale
d'idées dans cette position des fois
quand vous avez un pion passé comme ça
on est un peu coincé on sait plus quoi
faire et les blancs ils ont dans ce
centre bouclé les perspectives allaient
le droit sur le roi noir quoi moche
d'accord avec des céphane les Noirs ont
aucun jeu
et du coup ce que je voulais dire c'est
que généralement quand vous quand vous
êtes contre un pion passé protégé comme
celui-là et ben c'est le cavalier qui va
venir bloquer ce pion donc on est
souvent cavalier bloqueur qui vient ici
en D3 pour pour empêcher le temps
d'avancer donc pourquoi cavaler plutôt
que d'autres pièces Kevin est-ce que tu
déjà il tape les soutiens ça c'est déjà
ce qu'on peut qu'on peut dire
on évite aussi de mettre les pièces
fortes en bloqueur parce qu'on les
monopolise finalement à la défense d'un
objectif ça soutient aussi la poussée
Beckham dans ce type de position un
moment si on veut débloquer la situation
on préfère bloquer avec les petites
pièces voilà
toutes les autres pièces un cavalier ici
il peut attaquer les soutiens donc les
pions qui vont défendre en fait le pion
des 4 et ensuite et ben j'ai souvent des
ruptures imaginons que nous pions E5
soit un pion noir aussi j'ai du F4 pour
casser
là-bas et aussi B4 pour casser un peu
tout ça et j'attaque en plus de pions on
tape les soutien on travaille c'est des
ruptures
très intéressant
on va même peut-être pas prendre la
peine de faire tout cela
parce qu'il y a pas de danger immédiat
j'aimerais bien commencer à travailler à
l'elroit alors est-ce que j'ai ces
moyens là
ce que je vais reparler du HK proposé
tout à l'heure
j'aimerais bien contrôler peut-être
quand même le contre genou noir faut
vérifier que les Noirs menacent je sais
pas C4 pour
essayer de trouver du jeu à l'aile dame
pour que ça justement ça s'envenime
cette position
en tout cas c'est une position plutôt
pédago
et regisy pour l'instant fait fait une
très bonne partie mais douce à Toro
Farid a joué assez rapidement une
position un peu un peu difficile en
améliorant ses pièces quand vous ne
savez pas trop quoi faire ben améliorer
vos pièces ça vous pouvez toujours le
faire
et du coup
on va peut-être faire on va continuer le
tour des stades ou pas allez donc on a
pas rame qui joue contre karwana
il se fait travailler comme on a Eddy le
pion on sait après ce que sera suffisant
pour gagner
est-ce que tu peux revenir sur le coup
F3 sous parce que je fais étonné qu'il y
a eu ce petit F3
j'ai l'impression c'est bizarre de créer
l'affaiblissement structurel alors il
s'est dit je menace 4 à terme parce que
tout de suite c'est un peu un peu
douteux mais
sauf qu'il y a eu B6 c'est maintenant ça
va être dur de mettre en classe 4 en
place mais il s'est dit si B si c'est
joué il y a le pion C6 qui est plus
faible et B6 dans la foulée
semblait plus logique de jouer juste
dames C3 avant B4 essayez de jouer du
côté aldam j'avais envie de faire ça
j'ai envie de travailler
ça me semblait plus logique de faire BK
et B5 évidemment
après sur les thèmes comme ça BK des
fois il est noir font B5 à laisser 8
Calais B6 maintenant il a pas trop le
temps
donc je sais pas pourquoi on fait pas B4
à 4 ici ça paraissait tellement plus
simple
bien sûr à 5 je fais quand même B4 en
tout cas ce que j'avais envie de faire
sauf
de jouer assez simple ah peut-être à 5
B4 et le petit tour à deux
il y a un petit tour à deux qui vient
attaquer le pot de
ah oui aussi très intéressant très très
intéressant
[Musique]
je vais pouvoir jouer avec tour à 8
comme tu le disais B6 aussi
donc il aurait fallu que j'attende un
petit peu
voilà c'est bien aussi les deux marches
mais l'idée est là en tout cas il va
falloir travailler comme ça maintenant
faut le mettre en place parce que sur A5
on n'est pas obligé de jouer B4
peut être un peu plus patient
elle s'est proposé F3 comme il a fait
4 pour accompagner et avoir la classe B1
aussi pour la tour
donc en F3 bon ok
c'est pas facile après maintenant
peut-être qu'il va replacer un jour le
Tour Eiffel voilà et on y va
pourquoi en fait ça on joue pour 4 si
c'est ce qu'il a indiqué le cavalier ça
tu es paralysé pour le moment
à la défense du pion C6 et B5 des Noirs
serait une faute positionnelle puisque
ça laisserait le pion C6 arrière et plus
l'accès à la casse C5 la vente
pressing quand même les
carronnages jouent pas vraiment ici pour
pour le gain normalement il y a une
petite un petit pressing blanc on a tout
un jouet ça joue ça joue très
normallement bonne partie de Max ou de
l'eau je trouve
alors Prague qu'est-ce qui nous fait la
petite Prague
c'est compliqué du jour
il est
il est devenu beaucoup mieux visiblement
contre Jordan van forest parce que c'est
vrai que si les Noirs n'arrivent pas à
créer quelque chose
d'ici quelques coups la Dame des blancs
va parler on a envie d'enlever le
carrier c'est trop on vous le rappelle
elle jouait
becketti un peu on vous rappelle donc
une fourchette qui oblige à prendre les
quatre pour réussir à jouer à 5 et du
coup c'est de bloquer vraiment le jeu
ici quoi et du coup après faut O2 on a
eu au 7 rock tourner un donc on veut
aussi garder le pion des 4 on avait dit
qu'elle avait problème souvent ce plan
des quatre qui ferme toute la position
n'a pas été du tout apprécié par l'ordi
sauf parce qu'on a les perspectives B4
il attaque n'est pas encore lancé est-ce
qu'on peut juste s'excuse regardez ce
qu'il fallait jouer à la place de 4 pour
comprendre un petit peu ça m'intéresse
de voir ce que les noirs auraient dû
jouer ce qu'il fallait jouer pour eux
prend des ou cavalier E4 comment on
avançait dans cette position
mais E4 surtout pas parce qu'il risque
de se coincer le contre le jeu
parce que en fait moi
je veux découvrir mon fou donc je bouge
mon cavalier on va regarder un truc
peut-être cavalier de juste pour voir
malheureusement
tout à l'heure on peut regarder parce
que c'est intéressant d'avoir si on
jouait un coup comme cavaliers à deux
comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure au même
cavaler on avait cette possibilité
là
pour nous
du coup on avait des fous de foulard
foulard et maintenant cavaler un juste
pour voir
d'ailleurs Cavalia de marché toujours
ouais mais là je suis fou maintenant
c'est quoi le problème
je comprends rien j'y vais on fait comme
si j'ai comme si je salut à tous ceux
qui arrivent
c'est marrant que l'ordinateur ici
ça paraît pas mais il y a des cavaliers
G5 qui trouvent des ressources
un peu folles
ok ok intéressant bon en tout cas il a
le solide ouais visiblement elle essaie
de trouver quand même quelque chose il
va jouer à chaque souffle il va essayer
d'embrouiller et humainement parlant
cette position ne font peur parce que
les Noirs vont arriver en retard avec
leur attaque elle est le roi
par rapport au blanc à l'ail dame mais
ils vont attaquer le roi donc même s'ils
arrivent
ça sent le seul
j'ai lu le petit message de Noah
pourquoi parce que finalement
peinard
c'était l'ancien l'ancien poulain de
stouffe
maintenant c'est
au fait tu es en difficulté contre Rega
ici donc ça sent pas du tout le sub et
au global il y a quand même il y a quand
même plus de
plus de
champ enfin il y a des chances encore
que le pari s'inverse il y a saut il y a
quand même deux choses
d'ailleurs par rapport à nos Paris tu as
mis quoi déjà Google je t'avais mis
Google
on va regarder du coup un peu ce qui se
passe donc dans cette partie là moi
j'avais parié sur 1-0 donc je suis pas
mal pour l'instant
et toi tu avais mis
il était bien il y a un coup non sauf
que je vois un coup
[Musique]
apparemment c'est gaffe de l'ordinateur
bon
ordinateur il aime pas il est pas trop
sûr
en tout cas ça avait l'air séduisant
j'avais pris des risques
parce que là il fait une grosse grosse
partie en là clairement à la différence
des pièces gardez la différence dans le
chat quelqu'un avait dit que tu meurs
était
le stuff
la profondeur malheureusement
18 donc il peut y avoir des petites
erreurs c'est pour ça que la jauge n'est
pas stabiliser véritablement
et Cyril nous dit c'est pas comme ça que
Dean va devenir champion du monde non là
il est en difficulté effectivement très
clairement
et là ben qui meurt qui a une superbe
partie
il s'est passé c'est quoi après la
maquette
tour D1 dame c'est 5 ça travaille on
échangeant E5 il est venu échanger les
dames et faire F4 5
facile cool on prend son temps
incompréhensible
est très dur
très dur pour pour
[Musique]
que j'ai pas
chargé d'idées
comme ça
quoi très intéressant ce coup ce courage
4 avec les Noirs je ne saurais pas
franchement
quoi jouer
ça chaud
je pensais m'aider avec ces quatre mais
je sais pas si j'arrive à le faire
mais si je le joue tu risques de manger
et là j'arrive pas à faire marcher mon
livre parce qu'en fait si je fais ça le
problème c'est que j'ai peur qu'un jour
tu me fasse un faux et tu me tourner un
donc
j'ai voulu faire marcher ça d'une autre
manière parce que je me suis dit que
peut-être que je pouvais faire genre C4
pion et manger F5 avec l'idée que si tu
prends du pion bah je peux avoir la même
idée avec surfaut 3 je peux avoir tout
orange à 4
mais le problème c'est que
je suis pas sûr que oups je suis pas sûr
que dans cette variante là
j'ai
tout reprend des
des 7 c'est jamais clair hein
donc du coup ça m'avait l'air compliqué
donc je regardais un truc comme ça mais
peut-être que je suis complètement non
mais c'est très compliqué je pense la
position après pour les joueurs c'est
dire c'est dire
et si je mange là du coup
tu manges de là c'était un premier de tu
vois
et donc peut-être du coup tu manges du
pionger
maintenant c'est quatre alors
complètement jouable mais il y a
beaucoup de choses à surveiller parce
que ça ça a l'air intéressant même si ça
vient quand même les 15 mars serait
fermé donc du coup je pourrais me tu vas
faire Dame des deux rois H2O peut-être
pas toujours les histoires de f-6 dans
ses positions à calculer qui n'est pas
ridicule c'est compliqué
par exemple à tout moment
c'est dur aussi quand même assumer
mais sur des trois je peux même faire
tout reprendre des trois je pense ça
aussi
parce que je pensais
c'est dur à
comprendre tout ça
des trois mais je suis pas sûr d'être
une bonne idée
peut-être que je suis pas dans le bon
truc
très très compliqué mais bon c'est clair
que les blancs
[Musique]
malgré le fait que la jauge n'est pas
aimé on préfère quand même le côté blanc
qu'il y a une certaine
pratique c'est quand même intéressant
quoi pour les blancs franchement
donc à voir avoir du coup là tu es pas
mal j'ai l'impression pour le pour le
pour Paris
où tu es bien et des paris où je suis
bête
[Musique]
sur ouais j'ai misgan noir et là pour
qu'il la gagne par exemple tu vois sauf
il faudrait que par hame se mettre
vraiment
vraiment mal tout seul
pour l'instant je vois pas trop encore
sûr que là je suis mieux ici
là je pense que je suis quand même mieux
donc tu vois
il va s'en passer encore
donc
[Musique]
voilà on va peut-être faire la petite
pause sauf
[Musique]
voilà et puis donc on vous dit
Adam et on vous met peut-être les
petites les petites choses comme ça on
va faire un petit saut Vertou déjà comme
ça vous avez les infos hop déjà un petit
saut comme ça vous pouvez nous suivre
pendant la pause il y en a qui
s'ennuient donc du coup on vous met des
petits des petits liens de partout j'ai
réussi mon saut du premier coup je suis
assez content de
moi je vous mets aussi un lancement de
la plateforme ce week-end avec le
nouveau pack comme il y a une réduction
ben profitez-en si ça vous dit d'aller
visiter la nouvelle plateforme en ligne
que j'ai mise en place il y a peu donc
ceux qui ne connaissent pas hop je vous
mets le lien du cadeau hop et du nouveau
pack comme ça vous êtes peinard vous
avez n'hésitez pas à venir visiter nos
sites moi j'ai aussi Youtube c'est tout
échec
je suis en train de lancer les des aussi
sur la chaîne donc tu nous as donné
envie hier soir avec une partie assez
mémorable
[Musique]
ce soir ou demain mais
n'hésitez pas en tout cas à venir
à venir à venir sur nos chaînes ça me
fera plaisir on stream régulièrement
donc là les événements c'est un peu plus
dur d'avoir la force de streamer après 7
heures de live mais
voilà mais en tout cas n'hésitez pas à
venir nous voir sur sur nos sites
respectifs moi j'ai aussi un site en
ligne je peux vous le montrer aussi une
petite seconde sur laquelle je donne des
cours donc pour l'instant bientôt va
avoir un truc qui va sortir ça je vous
dis j'en dirai plus un peu plus tard
mais si vous voulez visiter mon site je
donne des cours sur ce site enfin
pouvez me contacter un peu là dessus que
c'était un si vous voulez progresser de
l'échec et puis
et puis bah écoute
on vous dit à tout de suite après Après
la Pub bonne pause progression aux
échecs vous allez visiter tout ça pour
progresser et vous faire plaisir en tout
cas avec nos et on vous souhaite un bon
goûter un bon goûter yes à tout de suite
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour avec Kevin et
oui c'est reparti voilà ça va être
balaise à une autre ici une petite heure
tout voilà on est on est parti pour pour
la période un petit peu compliqué pour
les joueurs il va falloir gérer les
positions et aussi la pendule
ouais donc salut Fatou salut à ceux qui
viennent d'arriver sur le chat salut au
nouveau hello tout le monde
je vais t'écrire en privé
tu vas parler
c'est un gros gros secret ah oui
ouais encore une fois sur un secret
comme ça j'ai pas pu t'aider tu vois ça
aurait pu tu vois un jour peut-être que
je te rendrai l'appareil souffle j'en
profite pour dire à tout le monde aussi
que donc là la stouffe il ostent le
stream c'est à dire que c'est lui qui
gère la technique et que prochainement
stouf n'étant pas chez lui c'est moi qui
vais gérer la technique pour le dernier
week-end et tout fier à gentiment pris
sur son temps alors qu'il était pas du
tout obligé de le faire puisque il y a
aussi des spécialistes au niveau de
shetcom qui gère cela mais pour m'aider
parce que j'aurais eu un une assistance
en anglais parce que il s'est dit allez
c'est mieux si si j'aide si j'aide Kevin
et du coup il a pris il a pris une heure
quasiment de son temps pour m'aider à
installer les les futurs scènes donc
merci à toi à tous et du coup vous
pouvez dire un grand merci à tous parce
qu'il donne de son temps aussi pour la
technique il y a pas que pour les échecs
voilà et ce stuff apparemment on a on a
tisé et des céphane il a il a envie de
connaître le secret voilà donc du coup
c'est
normal
c'est plus qu'à avoir envoyé donc pas
tout je crois qu'elle est partie en fait
elle est pas là elle fait genre qu'elle
est là mais en fait elle est pas là
du coup alors on était sur la position
de gamer qui presse vraiment d'Igny
Rennes qui a une position assez
assez poubelle avec le pion à 4 qui est
un peu faiblard il a beau avoir la
majorité elle dames c'est pas une
majorité qui se met en marche et surtout
les deux tourbes blanches font peur
l'arrivée d'un fou éventuellement des 7
l'idée de pousser E5 d'avoir cavalier E4
d'amener le roi aussi vers le centre Roy
F2 roi E3 franchement on a trop envie de
jouer la position avec les Blancs c'est
gros avantage
pour les blancs on a la deux tours sur
la colonne D et les pièces bien placées
quand vous regardez la tour à huile
quand vous regardez le cavalier
G8 ça fait quand même
un peu mal au cœur donc
dur pour Ding
oui
on pensait qu'il allait après sa
première partie vraiment bien performée
dans ce tournoi finalement s'il venait à
s'incliner ça serait tout l'inverse ça
serait même un mauvais signe pour ses
futurs championnats du monde qui vont
arriver quand même rapidement
mine de rien il est en face de
préparation ça y est il est complètement
dedans
donc psychologiquement ben il faut il
faut se mettre au mieux pour cet
échéance et là il faut pas qu'il perde
aujourd'hui pourtant il est mal barré
ici
il faut encore faire des choses
qui meurt elle a pris un gros gros plus
dans cette vidéo une partie
il était pas très en forme dans le
tournoi et là elle a une position hyper
facile à jouer il sait qu'il peut pas la
perdre donc c'est confort pour lui alors
qu'il y a pas de danger donc c'est
beaucoup plus simple
alors est-ce qu'on fait un petit tour
on a fait une petite pause et j'ai
l'impression que c'est passé les choses
dans toutes les parties à chauffer chez
Magnus là aussi on voit qu'il y a eu des
choses il y a eu des cinq
donc on a parlé de ça
il a tout trouvé je crois Richard
rapporte et cavaler 4
on voit que la jauge n'a pas n'a pas
bougé donc c'était la séquence à trouver
il fallait ouvrir le roi de Magnus pour
tenir dans cette position donc c'était
une fausse égalité c'est finalement plus
une position incertaine sauf ouais il y
a une pièce d'avance pour pour Magnus
mais du jeu du jeu du jeu sur le roi il
y a du jeu
ok il y a le pion Descartes qui peut
tomber et là il y a eu trois apparemment
c'était pas un bon coup
et rose dormant qu'on a vu Ding en
interview qui a dit qu'il allait qui
allait jouer au maximum toutes ces
parties pour se préparer pour le chemin
donc je pense qu'il fait vraiment pas
exprès de faire des résultats qui sont
très moyens pour le moment et qui serait
même qui commencera de venir mauvais en
cas de défaite voilà alors peut-être
qu'au niveau ouverture il en garde un
peu sous le pied mais c'est pas trop
l'impression qu'il en donne hier il
était très déçu de s'annule contre les
von a rognan donc je pense qu'il a envie
de bien performant bien performer il a
besoin d'être en confiance pour aborder
son choix du monde
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait jouer bah
c'était pas facile apparemment alors
mais en quoi est-ce que
moi c'est pas facile à comprendre à la
petite subtilité
de cette position d'avoir provoqué G3 ça
faiblit peut-être un petit peu les cases
tout mais c'était vraiment pas évident à
voir
pas simple
mais il a pas il a pas créé le petit à
faiblissement dans cette position donc
laquelle deux pions pour la pièce et un
troisième
ici il y a un seul coup pour l'avantage
je trouve c'est tout frais fin s'il y
avait le pion G3 on avait foi
ok voilà mais bon c'était extrêmement
difficile à trouver la Carlsen peut
reconstruire sa cabane faire un vrai
rock à la main c'est ça en fin de
l'histoire
et malheureusement de ces femmes
nonci puisque Magnus tu l'as peut-être
vu à décider d'abandonner son titre de
champion du monde donc c'est son
challenger
qui maintenant c'est même pas son
charger finalement c'est le deuxième du
tournoi des candidats qui est repêché
pour pour aller discuter le championnat
du monde voilà
donc digne va affronter ne pas match
non c'est pas génial pour Ding se
tournoi mais il faut qu'il ne perde pas
aujourd'hui
faut pas perdre
[Musique]
je prends des 4 tout simplement et puis
il y a les pièces s'échangent et puis
mon roi qui va réussir à venir ici puis
au final mon roi sera quand même bien
développé enfin bien caché pendant que
ton roi des grands rock c'est pas
évident oui et puis en fait il y a trois
pions pour la pièce et les trois pions
ne sont pas dangereux pour l'instant ils
sont pas en marche il y a que le Pione 4
qui est bien avancé mais il est pas
accompagné ils sont déliés ces trois
pions c'est pas trois pions passés qui
feraient un bloc sauf
c'est il y a le pion le cadre le pion
Cécile le pion F7 ils sont pas encore
tous ensemble pour faire mal on va
expliquer un pourquoi il y avait aucun
joueur français à lire et zafiruja
il est pas en accord parfait avec
l'organisation depuis un problème il y a
2 ans la dernière ronde
et mvl n'a pas nécessairement refilé
l'invitation peut-être qu'il l'aurait
refusé mais en tout cas apparemment il
l'a pas eu parce qu'il y a d'autres
joueurs de tout premier plan qui sont
présents dans cette compétition plus
beaucoup de jeunes pépites souffrent
vraiment
sympa parce qu'il y a vraiment la
meilleure joue du monde donc tu as tu as
400 ta digne tu as qu'à remettre etc et
tu as plein de jeunes qui qui montent en
puissance comme keemer présenta
érigasi abdotorov etc donc c'est
vraiment un truc intergénérationnel
l'impression et du coup il privilégie
plus les jeunes qui montrent plutôt que
les les habitué quoi tout simplement
salut fils
mais oui c'est sympa d'ailleurs Cyril
nous dit c'est sympa de voir tous ces
pépites
il trouve tout un Carlsen
beau visage de caracène dans cette
partie il a pas raté grand chose hein
quoi qu'il a rien raté pour l'instant
ça nous change des parties qu'il avait
perdu
là il est en train de faire mal à
Richard à la porte il fait plutôt une
jolie partie Richard importante
et pour l'instant il a juste pas trouvé
l'histoire de faire damaska DAF 6
directement c'est horrible pour lui
il faut faire mieux que bien
Kevin j'ai trouvé comment faire pour
pour
ce que tout à l'heure clique sur le
paramètre configuration
et après le tout en haut le premier faut
que tu le mettes
déjà montré mais bon j'avais déjà oublié
parce que Fatou elle m'écrit mais Fatou
à part à me dire des bêtises elle n'a
pas du tout
et ici les les blancs sont bien ok
Eric Asie alors il s'est passé plein de
choses aussi en donc il y a eu damassis
du coup sur
sur H4 avec des d'apprendre à deux et
aussi des trois on en parle hyper
intéressant
dans le B3
ok donc ils vont anticiper des trois
il aime bien prendre les pions donc il
devrait pas aimer les données alors lui
à manger tous les pions n'importe
laquelle et après il
et du coup c'est vrai que là il défend
ses petits pions
j'aime bien les blancs quand même
j'aime bien les gens comme ça c'est
ouvert ensemble c'est moins clair que
tout à l'heure il faut
qui a été joué je trouve que c'est
compliqué à j'ai du mal maintenant à
évaluer alors que tout à l'heure j'ai
l'impression que c'était à sens unique
et là est très belle réaction de cette
Europe au centre maintenant je trouve
que c'est le bazar et il y a l'avant au
temps
donc des trois H5 vient de jouer
des trois H5
[Musique]
il y a peut-être prises et qui a été 4
peut-être
est-ce qu'on peut jouer cari dk4u c'est
pas sûr dans cette position c'est
possible en tout cas que des quatre
cavaler prend pour prendre et sur ici je
te reprends F4 je me demandais si on
pouvait pas faire un des trois il y
aurait échange de dames et cavaliers eux
deux
trois alors maintenant toujours cavalier
2 donc il y a un problème avec cavalier
2 souffre c'est ok
prends
bah ça fait une découverte sur la tour
et surtout reprend des trois qui défend
bon jusqu'à va les prendre
dans un élan de montrer tous les thèmes
autour de la prison des trois et finit
par oublier la dame
voilà
le roi Dario
ah voilà ouais on est on est pas loin
d'avoir quand même
d'avoir manger ici bien sûr
et surprise faire échec je pense ou même
manger là aussi bien tout de suite je
crois avec dames et 6 sur Wii F1
la
il a mal négocié la rayoncé c'est sûr
que c'est la séquence c'est fou pour F5
forcée puis on prend cavalier des quatre
facile à trouver
il va être il va être juste très mal
quand le roi il est ouvert comme ça il
faut ouvrir la position c'est clairement
ce qu'il faut faire alors si on joue pas
F6 dans cette position je vais peut-être
fouger 3 directions
en tout cas là ça s'est complètement
inversé maintenant c'est les Noirs après
fougères je pense que ce sera la partie
cette position
parce que sur dommage
donc j'ai tout trois
dommages 6
mais
c'est très intéressant quand même
surtout que maintenant on en prend un
championnat mettre après sur la tour D1
peut-être que sur da machine je peux
jouer tour D3
non tu échangerais autour des 8
peut-être
c'est hyper dur à calculer en plus
la difficulté ici maintenant pour
réaliser est-ce que ça va être joué mais
je pense que oui dans cette position
en plus sur le au-delà d'être naturel
si on tient compte le pion des la finale
ok alors parrain contre
contre carvana bassin tourne un peu en
rond
Dame des 7 4
ok donc ça améliore à chaque coup c'est
d'améliorer
parce que c'est plus trop comment
avancer
j'arrive pas à le ramener à la maison
et même la dame B2 qui est venue à la
défense de du pion
E3 et voilà la prise 4 là c'est vraiment
un parti pris on va donner le centre
mais ce sont des pions pendant un petit
C5 peut-être 5 D6 là c'est l'idée je
pense mais on peut pas le jouer tout de
suite
donc il va falloir jouer dans ce Goula
mais pas tout de suite
mais là les Blancs ont du mal à
progresser la pion sont faibles autour
des 7 très joli
beaucoup d'élégance chez Fabiano carbona
dans cette dans cette partie
un beau grand
c'est bizarre ça
il est en train de perdre les pédales
Richard apporte sur un très beau jeu de
de Magnus
et qu'est-ce qu'il veut raconter avec ce
damage 4 on a à peine à le comprendre
roi j'ai un fou G4 peut-être
mais ça menace rien
et puis ça laisse F7 ça laisse le
fousser 5 en l'air
en difficulté ici donc moi j'ai un jouet
très vite par par Magnus
on va voir la caméra parce qu'il a pas
encore joué la caméra de la Mascate
vous allez le voir je veux ça et c'est
vrai que ça a l'air
ça a l'air pas bon du tout ah il a foutu
c'était ça son idée mais est-ce que ça
marche tout reprend F5 est-ce que c'est
jouable
que maintenant qu'on a vu la jauge il a
déjà pris Magnus
donc là ça vaut le coup de voir à la cam
mais il a fougé en fait
le séisme et sur ça j'ai juste 3 F2
il y avait tout calculé
il va bientôt
bientôt pleurer
parce que c'est Magnus en face
là c'est une évaluation qui qui fait
hyper mal donc on peut imaginer que
Richard apporte à oublier que Magnus
pouvait faire tourner F5
en plus ils sont nul forcer genre j'ai
trois fous prends G3 sauf quelque chose
comme ça ah non ça faisait pas nul dans
ce cas là c'est bizarre qu'est-ce qu'il
a raté il pensait que Magnus allait
jouer quoi s'il n'avait pas tout reprend
F5 il n'avait rien Magnus
ah oui Dudule on est bien d'accord avec
toi faut prendre H2 roi et fin que faut
prendre H2 roi H1 serait bien plus
modeste après foi F4
mais du coup voilà il y aura toujours
dans toutes les variantes maintenant
est-ce qu'on pourrait essayer les il y a
pas de vraiment de thème pour carotter
c'est quand même deux pièces
donc damage 2 c'est presque mieux mais
roi F1 même royal
mais bon ça c'est clairement le coup
on pourrait carotter le feu 3 pardon
mais du coup ok position c'est assez
esthétique quand même peut-être que
Richard apporte il avait arrêté je sais
pas à fois H2 oublions Roy F2 enfin ça
doit être un truc un peu horrible
d'un point H2 a été joué
de toute façon
sauf tout en fait faut que j'ai un c'est
terrible c'est une pièce en moins
comme il y en avait déjà ouais là ça va
être ça va être vraiment du coup c'est
deux pièces pour trois pions ça vaut pas
hein
c'est une faute professionnelle
oui c'est sûr c'est sûr c'est un très
mauvais calcul pour un joueur de ce rang
après on sait que ça arrive c'est pas
évident
non c'est vrai que ça paraît pas si
complexe ça paraît pas si complexe mais
après c'est toujours pareil les mecs ils
ont l'impression du temps ils voulaient
pas se laisser distancer ils avaient 20
coups effectué et du coup c'est vrai
qu'il s'est trompé il a fait confiance
son calcul je sais pas trop ce qu'il a
raté stouf qu'est-ce qu'il a raté il a
raté bah je sais pas il a oublié la Casa
c'est vrai que ça paraît pas si dur
peut-être qu'il était peut-être qu'il
était
il était enfin il se sentait très très
mal avant et qu'il a fait au lit quoi
parce qu'il a une pièce de moins bon
nous on a la jauge et tout ça mais
du coup c'est du bon vas-y c'est bon on
y va quoi
mais là là par contre ça a l'air
ça a l'air juste perdu
d'ailleurs
ok je pense sera le premier régime de la
journée je pense et avec erikaze qui a
joué
exactement notre ligne avec avec
6 qui va arriver aussi qui défendra ici
et aussi le pion
H5 en tout cas ça me fait mal parce que
là abdos il est devant très clairement
ouais alors on avait déjà vu la partie
de param alors Prague où est-ce qu'il en
est
on s'est arrêté du coup c'est vraiment
il y avait eu quatre cet arrêté là il y
avait cavalua Fougères
H3
[Musique]
faut prendre en cavalier prend et là
menace B4 avec tour reprend etc bien sûr
là
il s'est mis en mode tortue en mode je
défends alors qu'il fallait c'est de
faire quelque chose pour Jordan van
forest c'est de monter un bateau à
l'aile le roi
et maintenant
et puis là on va voir un peu un cavaler
C2
total quoi on peut imaginer qui va être
un cavalier en B4 un cavalier en B3 et
pousser le pion je crois à 6
ouais
la difficulté c'est qui je suis obligé
d'en rendre le tenir et après il y aura
une avalanche quoi cavalier B3 menace
cavalier A5 il va me mettre dur à tenir
tu vois c'est galère quoi
là c'est c'est la cagoule
ok Google
[Musique]
alors on va revenir en s'arrêter à
cavalière 5
vous l'avez joué 4 cavalier H5 qui a eu
c'est un contrôle la case F4 très bien
joué F4
sans doute
donc il y a eu droit à 8
pour en libérer le plan fièrement
cavalier H4 on va piquer le flou blanc
et sur le 6 dames des 1 attention au
petit cavalier qui peut traîner ici ah
oui dame D8
B5
donc là les blancs qui commencent à
avoir à prendre un petit peu l'avantage
d'espace
il faut prendre aussi si on ramène le
cavalier peut-être c'est 4c5
on peut aussi jouer contre
le cavalier à 5 à tout moment
il faut qu'on fasse gaffe à notre
cavalier H4
[Rires]
on travaille la pause les pièces
blanches sont beaucoup plus belles que
tout à l'heure les pièces noires c'est
différent c'est plus possible
il a 22 minutes à la pendule
sa position c'est nettement améliorée
franchement il a réussi un bon tour de
passe-passe quelques gouttes
blanches donc il y avait eu
fougé de cavaliers
va bouger la tour donc là il y a encore
un bel avantage blanc avec les deux
tours sur la colonne des et les tournois
qui ont du mal à exprimer et aussi un
pur en prise en 24 est-ce qu'il est
prenable ou pas
peut-être pour reprendre
assez logique d'aller le prendre sinon
tour des trois tours C4 et tour des 7
est-ce que ça peut aboutir à quelque
chose
si on fait cavalier B5 derrière oui mais
c'est pas sûr qu'on réussisse
salut mec
hello
comme condamné c'est pas la peine de
défendre
et Dino Magnus il est déjà gagnant
il est gagnant un rapport qui s'est
suicidé complètement
il va trouver parce que là c'est
calculatoire mais si vous on peut aller
voir un petit peu on va voir un peu
vu que ça va être peut-être
la fin de la partie c'est de rester un
peu là-dessus il a deux pièces d'avance
en fait contre quelques pions mais pas
suffisamment pour pour être inquiétant
donc là sur un fou H2 bah j'ai trois F2
la dame défend et on va échanger des
pièces et
pour essayer de te faire prendre un F7
et puis mettre une tour en F8
mais je pense que tu me prendras pas non
si je suis trop gourmand il y aura tout
à fait qui va
prendre du contre jeu c'est pas sûr que
ce soit suffisant mais dans l'idée ça
ramène un peu de contre je crois
que c'était suffisant mais même ça c'est
peut-être pas donc c'est pour montrer la
marche qu'on a avec les blancs dans
cette pose
le mur c'est effrité et le jeu de
rapporte a été ambitieux
il était pas loin de quelque chose mais
il fallait être ultra précis grosse
partie de Carlson
va gagner la partie en 20 coups après
l'ouverture
tu vois une pétrole comme ça tu le dis
pas que ça va gagner en vaincu quoi au
cinquième dame de 7 victoires en vinco
avec deux pièces d'avance c'était
j'aurais pas parié sur ça en tout cas
Carlson avait joué une des ouvertures
les plus solides pour on peut vous
montrer rapidement
ce qui avait été joué peut-être sauf
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent
j'ai mis l'automatique cheesecom pas mal
ça le pilote auto est de retour
donc juste avec le petit cavalier F4
mieux placé dans ces variantes et on
joue aux échecs
il a dit si tu veux qu'on garde la dame
on la garde et après il a réussi à bien
bloquer son adversaire et avoir de
l'avance dans les recopés qui est obligé
Richard rapport à essayer de jouer très
créat à filer une pièce pour l'attaque
et il s'est trompé complètement dans un
calcul visiblement ici où il a redonné
un fou en plus pour
une petite attaque sur le roi qui ne va
pas aboutir
il y a rien du tout et pourtant ton aide
c'est une souligne en fait car les trois
mais qui est assez à la mode en ce
moment donc on peut pas dire que c'est
un mauvais coup c'est une idée
intéressante dans l'ouverture quoi avec
les Blancs on a beaucoup de souplesse en
règle générale à moins de jouer un coup
complètement incohérent on a quand même
pas mal de choix donc c'est une
une Web plutôt une jolie variante c'est
Maxime va chez Lagrave qui la jouer
récemment je l'ai étudié récemment avec
un élève ce qu'on avait vu avec stouf au
speedchait et au championnat du monde de
partir rapide et Blitz du coup j'avais
été la regarder mais pas celle avec qui
me paraissait plus modeste même si là ça
a été un gros freestyle
Maxime Vacher la grave il joue sans dame
de dame 7 pour garder les pièces sur les
chéquiers et bastonner et là on a vu que
Richard rapporte a été très ambitieux il
a jamais échangé dame finalement surtout
qu'il aurait peut-être dû faudrait
peut-être dû échanger
après c'est pas trop son style de jeu
à rapport ici un de la finale pour faire
nul
comme les positions où ça joue
exactement mais il a vu le choix de la
pétrole ça a été dit dans le stream il y
a quelques-uns qui disait ouais c'est
bizarre rapporte c'est plutôt Gumball et
là il a joué
il a joué sa petite pétrole et
franchement ça a mal
tourné pour lui
ouais mais originaux Magnus si en fait
il a proposé l'échange de dame très
rapidement parce que Magnus il est connu
pour être
le joueur technique par excellence donc
ça le dérangeait pas tant que ça
d'échanger les dames non plus qu'on ne
Richard rapporte qui est plutôt un grand
attaquant très CREA etc
la problématique c'est qu'on s'est
retrouvé plutôt dans un dans une
position où le style de Richard rapporte
est valorisé et même dans ce style là
Magnus et lui aussi plus fort quoi je
dirais que Magnus il est meilleur en
tout en fait tout simplement quoi bah
oui mais c'est vrai que ouais je suis
assez d'accord avec Néandertal il a pris
parlé aux oiseaux rapporte parce que
il a quand même raté un gros calcul et
pour pour son niveau pour son style de
jeu c'est moyennement normal voilà
ouais en fait on voit que ouais c'est ça
exactement le goat
c'est très très dur de jouer contre
carcennes de savoir comment il faut
faire on rappelle que Carcassonne a
perdu deux fois effectivement dans le
tournoi mais c'est rarissime et c'est
parti comme tout grand champion hier il
a fait une jolie partie contre le jardin
de Forest avec des pièces noires même
s'il a fait que nul ben c'était les
pièces noires il a poussé légèrement et
maintenant c'est reparti avec les Blancs
et ça oui non
est-ce qu'il va revenir jusqu'au bout
avec souffle des gens on en parlait et
on est en train de voir que
le come-back d'ailleurs d'ailleurs au vu
de cette partie est-ce que tu veux
prendre
dans les trois premiers mais moi je
voulais parler ça si je sais je sais
c'est pour ça que je te dis ça
laisse moi voir le classement
je vais vous montrer le classement en
direct comme ça je vais prendre ma
décision il y a ton show qui demande se
trouve tu vas savoir lui répondre quand
est-ce que c'est quand est-ce le
prochain jour de pause jour lundi
lundi et jeudi
voilà et du coup demain on a encore au
manette
donc pour l'instant on a 4 et demi sur 6
donc là on voyait qu'il y a deux joueurs
qui ont quatrième sur 7 et 4 sur 7 parce
qu'ils ont ils ont fini ils ont fait nul
dans cette partie donc du coup ça fait
4,5
qui va gagner il va arriver à 3h30
moitié du tournoi il a le temps pour
revenir il sera la moyenne normalement
sauf séisme
j'ai réussi à retour tu vois j'ai eu
raison d'attendre hier tu es retourné le
pari ouais
c'est ça quoi
il faut il faut qu'on fasse le point à
la fin surtout qu'on se court pas
mais déjà tu marques des points à câble
d'où ça t'auras on sent
non Magnus doit être dans les trois
premiers
non de ces fans désolé on parle entre
nous bien sûr voilà et on passera dans
les stream respectifs régler nos dettes
on se doit beaucoup je crois
pour vous dire je fais les comptes je
dois 35 bastouf et stuff il m'en doit 22
sachant que finalement c'est 27 qui m'en
a déjà payé 5 en fait il a déjà il est
déjà passé dans un stream et on a une
problématique c'est qu'on est on est
comment dirais-je ben moi en stream sur
nos chaînes respectives comme la liste
tout à l'heure parce qu'on est beaucoup
sur chetcom sous encore plus que moi
puisqu'il a fait la couverture quasi
intégrale de l'événement sauf le dernier
week-end
pour ma part j'ai aussi les cours en
semaine c'est pour ça que j'arrivais pas
à tout déplacer c'est trop compliqué
donc voilà on a on a fait nos choix mais
en tout cas on est hyper content de
couvrir cet événement parce que comme on
vous l'a déjà dit lorsqu'on commentait
je fais du monde et de Blitz et rapide
le niveau est tel que pour nous ça reste
hyper intéressant à regarder à commenter
de comparer comme on le fait avec
souffle là les coups qu'on aurait joué
et de voir les petites subtilités
d'ailleurs tout concept qui nous faisait
peur
voilà il s'en fout il joue
[Musique]
c'est presque nous qui avons le jeu sauf
c'est nous qui m'attend
c'est juste gagné je pense c'est juste
gagnant très bientôt
il a pris un
donc dans la partie de Gazi il y a eu 3
comme on avait prévu
les joueurs vaut mieux aller respecter
parce que vu ce qui produit je peux te
dire que pour nous qui jouons avec avec
stouf depuis très très longtemps
c'est extrêmement fort c'est extrêmement
fort ce qu'on voit hier la ronde était
était assez incroyable on essaie d'être
objectif c'est à dire que on dit par
exemple Richard rapporte qui est une des
légendes du jeu Ben surtout dans l'air
moderne et là il a raté un calcul comme
simple pour lui ça empêche pas de dire
quand même quand quand les mecs font des
bêtises parce que les joueurs sont
faillibles on a vu d'ailleurs Magnus
faire des grosses bêtises dans plusieurs
tournois mais par exemple contre
artemief il a donné une pièce en un coup
avec 10 minutes à la pendule contre une
minute c'était au cheval du monde de
Blitz ou rapide et de toute façon je ne
sais plus parce qu'il a gagné les deux
donc même Magnus qui réussit quasiment
tout lui aussi
fait quelques bêtises forcément mais sur
l'ensemble des coûts joués la précision
est je sais pas à combien de précisions
il va finir manus dans cette partie mais
il a quasiment joué tous les coups non
c'est pas l'impression qu'il ait fait un
coup à côté est-ce que je peux regarder
je crois un analyse on pourrait mettre
la précision en cours
97,5 pour l'instant wagonus
sur une partie assez complexe en plus
stouf merci tabou cool
et en fait ouais la performance c'est ça
parce que Manu il fait régulièrement des
parties à plus de 98 mais ce qui est
dingue je trouve c'est de le faire dans
une partie aussi Gamble que celle là
quoi ah oui mais là il y a eu le roi qui
c'est des roquet au 11e coup elle croit
F2
et faire une partie parfaite
ça ressemble un peu à rien enfin je veux
dire c'est vraiment la baston quoi
on peut quand même dire que c'était plus
difficile pour Richard Laporte qui lui a
88 je pense qu'il y a eu plus de
décisions un peu difficile à prendre que
Magnus dans cette dans cette partie
c'est pas forcément égal à même si la
même partie selon les couleurs il y a
des moments des fois qui sont plus
chauds pour une couleur que pour l'autre
mais quand même c'est une performance
assez incroyable
franchement on est gâté avec cette
partie alors que ça part ça paraissait
tout timide gros choix de Richard
rapport on va jouer solide aujourd'hui
ça a pas manqué c'est parti en freestyle
total
il y a eu le petit dommage 6 de de
bien qui est qui est qui est entraîneur
qui le coach de d'Abdou on trouve tous
les coups un coach le coach tout et à
trouver le
côte son poulain on est arrivé à cette
position tout à l'heure dans les
analyses
il y a quelques quelques minutes
c'était vraiment fort logique c'est une
grosse partie parce qu'elle est égality
a pas fait n'importe quoi il s'est
peut-être un tout petit peu précipité
avec mais en même temps ça doit de jouer
ses couleurs je me serais bien vu les
jouer et apparemment bah c'était pas
c'était pas si fino
donc là tout à l'heure j'avais envie de
jouer tour des trois souffles pour
essayer de contrer le choix que je ferai
sur tour des trois je voyais bien tout
reprendre
dame prend tour des 8 et d'un F3
il y a eu un point B7
de Pierre il l'appelle enfin c'est pas
de pierre et bien l'appeler l'acrobate
j'ai regardé tout à l'heure de me
prendre sa tête et d'un F3 d'ailleurs
mais c'était mieux pour des trois non
ça paraissait plus logique
que si je donne le pion h il y aura
peut-être H5 H4 un moment ok c'est un
peu même si le variante
c'est chaud aussi cette position
et là on va avoir des gros zeignotes
stouf où il y aura de l'animation
je me disais peut-être qu'on va on
essaie d'échanger d'armes faire roi F1
Royal
garder c'est cool hein pour gagner ça
paraît mieux sinon il y aura match nul
là ça a l'air de vraiment plus annulant
quand même
des deux et après pour ces 8 toursiens
[Musique]
500 ouais mais j'ai toujours tout droit
donc ça peut vite fait
embêtant peut-être qu'on peut revenir un
petit peu avant et j'ai l'impression
qu'on pouvait un peu mieux faire avec
les blancs avec un petit tour citron
intercalé
je suis pas sûr que noir ne puisse pas
garder on verra après et là est-ce que
je peux jouer tour ces trois directement
plutôt stouf ouais
bon coup parce que là je vais gagner le
tempo sur la tour
elle n'aime pas trop d'en prendre un
impression
pourtant si logique pourtant
[Rires]
c'est pas débile parce que tu prends le
fou par exemple
qui a l'air quand même de
qui avait l'air en tout cas pas si
débile
très bien vu
j'aime beaucoup le collier
très fort
et du coup ouais
il y a une pression maintenant pression
noire à la réaction centrale a été
terrible et vous voyez qu'après fouger 5
c'est un peu décevant pour les blancs
qui ont poussé tout leur pions mais qui
ne menacent plus grand chose avec ses
pions E5 F5 H5 tout à fait pousser le
roi juste c'est il est trop faible quoi
j'ai un pion en D2
ça a l'air mal parti pour irrigazie qui
qui envoie un petit peu trop j'ai
l'impression
mais il a pas froid aux yeux
c'est aussi caractérise ces joueurs
aussi au delà d'être très bon ils n'ont
pas peur et ça c'est vraiment une
qualité que vous devez avoir en fait aux
échecs il faut être ultra méfiant mais
pas peureux et si vous avez ces qualités
là c'est parfait
faut faire les vérifications mais
n'avoir peur de rien et Regal easy qui a
un top player il le sait bien
maintenant des fois il pousse un peu
trop loin ce genre d'histoire et du coup
là on gagne un temponate parce que genre
je joue le tour C3 dans ma chambre c'est
vraiment une grosse amélioration de ce
qu'on regardait
et on pourra mettre une pression encore
plus importante
sur ça
et pour ces 8 du coup peut-être et je
peux peut-être en plus garder garder les
dames ça c'est une première hypothèse
mais je suis pas du tout obligé de
rentrer là-dedans
déjà ça fait peur
in extremis F4 bim
une bonne nouvelle
très bonne nouvelle même mais c'est pas
ça va pas être la suite de la partie
pour ces trois dans ma chambre peut-être
la tour C3 c'est bien c'est logique avec
des tours
qu'il faudra
regarder donc damage 5 je pense que
c'est quand même un coup assez logique
d'un F3 et là est-ce que je peux jouer
un coup comme damage 3
pour garder garder les dames et
construire
ça empêche la musique
et je garde le pressing mais deux sont
jouables on peut jouer la finale ou
garder le pressing
et il y a aussi une idée stuff à
laquelle je pensais tout à l'heure qu'on
a réussi à carotter le pion h à terme
peut-être qu'on pourrait avoir des idées
de H5 tours G4 H4
non c'est clair que c'est très très bien
pour les problèmes
f6o 6 mais ça a l'air d'être quasi
gagnant pour pour
faire une sacrée défense
après vu que l'on a constaté hier avec
avec erghisy il est capable de poser des
problèmes encore et de rendre la vie
difficile à
parce qu'il faut aussi jouer ces
positions là et ne pas abdiquer c'est
pas si clair encore la position est
bordélique donc humainement on peut on
peut craquer mais c'est dur
les deux ils sont super
ah mais ils ont une super mentalité les
deux regga easythora enfin tous
d'ailleurs pour être à ce niveau-là
au-delà de leur niveau technique il est
incroyable donc ils ont une puissance de
calcul et tout ça il faut aussi avoir
des qualités humaines de compétiteurs
hyper hyper développé et c'est ce qui
est cultive ils sont encadrés c'est ces
jeunes pépites mais on voit on voit
qu'ils ont à peu près tout aux échecs
avec des tours prend des 8 en cas de
tour des 8 et dame prend F7 l'embrouille
ouais ça s'embrouille quand même donc du
coup ouais
Ding était très mal au temps
dans celle-là il y a encore 15 coups
avec 20 minutes à la pendule je pense ça
l'a tranquille quand même pour aura
besoin
et du coup maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va
avoir
pas mal aussi
mais c'est plus long quoi peut-être que
les Noirs ont le temps de manger le truc
avec s'installer un peu mais bon ça va
pas rester comme ça trop de problème je
pense dans la position
dans bet3 alors bien aussi
car si vous voulez
vous avez la caméra sur 45 donc il y a
eu on l'avait dit un dam machin il y a
eu juste pour prendre un F7 et fousser4
sur tout reprend F7 F fois H2O F2
et là c'est juste perdu
là c'est juste perdu
en jeu surtout reprend fou prend
pour pour essayer de t'embrouiller
[Musique]
peut-être manger hein mais j'ai pas
envie de prendre la tête juste ce pion
il fait un peu parapluie tu vois je fais
dame ranger deux j'ai pas vu
de t'embrouiller j'ai pas vu d'un point
j'ai deux du coup bon là ça me reste
c'est un truc plus de cases voilà
on reprend là je laisse quand même d'en
prendre deux ça peut être un problème
même si je pense pas qu'il y a grand
chose
il en F3 mais ici en fait
si tu prends je prends surtout en effet
je dois MP3 qui va défendre avec Dame là
il faut calculer faut prendre en arrière
par exemple ça ça
le problème c'est que j'ai pas d'échec
et je suis cloué donc j'ai peut-être au
moins cavalieux de tu vois
mais bon j'ai déjà échec qu'elle a aussi
oui
sûrement un match avec cavalier A4
même là
et sur le roi ici je prends un tour sur
échec
est parti ici j'aurais eu
un fou ces quatre ce matin en 3 1
je suis cloué je peux pas mourir
tu es en train de regarder Migri
blanc point d'interrogation
je peux vous le donner si vous voulez il
faudrait que j'aille regarder aussi
vous dire qui suit dans le chat
on yes
et du coup oui en tout cas on a bien vu
ça va être très très dur pour Richard
rapporte
on a so Ding demain on a Guiri Kemer on
aura Abdou aronyan van forest herigasi
rapport Prague
kerwana Carlson et gokuge
donc pour digne il a intérêt il a
intérêt de ne pas perdre aujourd'hui
sinon ça peut commencer à être difficile
mais oui
on est tous d'accord on a été déçu par
la partie d'un rognan
et un peu plus pardon franchement je
suis pas très très loin d'un perfect
dans mes dans mes dans mes pronostics du
jour non non cookes
ça reste probable aussi ça reste
possible voilà Carlson 1-0 rapports
[Musique]
ça a l'air pas mal aussi c'est vrai et
harmonium guéri nul
et le plus dur pour moi c'est qui est
murding où j'ai prévu à nul et
dim qui est quand même en souffrance
mais bon tout peut se passer on sait que
ça ça tourne vite
[Rires]
et du coup ça fait un petit moment qu'on
avait pas allé voir d'ailleurs Ding et
Kemer goûters chaud
alors attends il y a eu
torréfi donc là on va voir dame B3 ça va
être abandon je pense ça va être ça va
être un moment au prochain coup
Kévin est-ce qu'on reste encore juste 2
minutes ici pour voir l'abandon en
direct d'un B3 e3w3 abondant je pense
je vois pas je vois pas comment il
pourrait continuer après ça
tout à l'heure je parlais du réveil
parce qu'il était affalé sur la table et
c'est pareil un petit réveil
qui sont de cloches
rapports
c'est pas mal le hello après oui par
rapport à Carlson et rapports
c'est un peu en dessous c'est un peu en
dessous
et par rapport à l'ensemble des joueurs
d'échec était bien tu es bien Robinson
hyper bien
du coup OK
Richard apporte il a plus plus beaucoup
de temps en plus derrière voilà
malheureusement Robinson tu as aussi dit
que tu jouais le Blackmar régulièrement
donc pour la compréhension réelle et
c'est toujours c'est toujours chaud
en tout cas robinside très bon Brice car
on leur a compris plutôt
je me rappelle d'un Robin side en feu il
me semble du coup que c'était
l'accession j'aurais dit 2007 session
[Musique]
c'est vrai
à part ne va pas abandonner et va être
bientôt
il y avait encore des tickets pour le
national a et à la dernière ronde je
vais contre Didier Colas pour la calive
dans le a
et j'ai eu la bonne idée de me qualifier
l'année suivante mais en se qualifié
pour le B cette fois malheureusement tu
as jamais fait le à toi
où je pouvais mais j'avais les Noirs
qu'on disait quoi là s'il m'a fait un
petit Réty il a bien bétonné avec les
Blancs j'ai fait nul
et fait 9 6 3
sur ces trois accessions successives et
le 3 c'était premier execos donc ça
qualifié pour le B tout le monde voilà
donc c'était cool et le a c'est un gros
gros tournoi on a parlé de l'énorme
tournoi de Jean-François Joly qui
c'était qualifié pour le a maintenant il
n'existe plus
yes donc Tourcoing donc là on va avoir
du coup
du coup la dame qui va rester en forme
mais je pense d'un match 4 un roi bouge
et il y a deux pièces de plus je me
laisse dame aussi c'est juste temps
perdu
même si tu vois que les Noirs arrivent
miracles raisons pas manger de fou en
fait ça part du coup
sera perdu
alors qu'est-ce que j'avais fait au B
donc c'était le B en 2009 du coup
puisque je me suis qualifié en 2008 et
OB je sais que je me suis recalifié donc
j'ai dû finir 5e je dirais
5e du B c'est à peu près ça donc je
crois que c'était mes deux premiers
partaient dans le a et après j'aurais
dit que les quatre suivants faudrait
vérifier que je dise pas de bêtises mais
j'étais plutôt content de mon résultat
j'avais surtout très très bien commencé
et l'année suivante par contre toujours
dans le B donc en maintenant dans le B
j'avais pris une bonne cagoule j'avais
fini onzième sur 12 c'était
Jean-François Joly qui avait fini qui
avait fermé la marche le bon collègue
breton qui avait permis de d'éviter la
dernière place mais ça avait été une
toute autre histoire le B si la première
fois ça a été super réussi la deuxième
fois c'était plutôt une une souffrance
ça dépend des fois
et marcounet tu nous dis très bien la
formule coupe l'an dernier oui c'est
vrai que elle a pas mal plu
après c'est toujours risqué un petit peu
ces matchs
ouais c'est tout à fait discutable mais
je pense que pour le spectacle en tout
cas ma reconnaître tu as raison ça a
beaucoup plu pour les joueurs c'est
beaucoup plus dur mais les joueurs
étaient assez contents je crois aussi je
trouve au final on a trouvé Jules Moussa
contre Baki bon bah j'avais parié sur
backi d'ailleurs et c'est Jules qui
était en très grande forme et c'était
pas loin de de vriller quand même on va
dire que c'était quand même les les deux
favoris
puisque Étienne est souvent au dessus de
de Laurent Freycinet par exemple en tout
cas il y a toujours la petite
pas le petit complexe mais c'est vrai
que
si les deux joueurs sont proches au
niveau du classement depuis toujours
on va dire que Laurent c'est quand même
un bon client d’étienne ils sont en
train de très bien tous les deux mais il
fait un petit peu fidéliser par Étienne
j'ai l'impression il a beaucoup de mal à
jouer contre lui
donc je trouvais que c'était assez
représentatif
des
choses le classement qu'on avait eu avec
un jus de Moussa qui a explosé depuis
maintenant un an et demi deux ans il
était tellement fort Jules mais on
l'attendait on attendait depuis très
longtemps et il avait du mal à confirmer
même il était pas assez un petit peu en
dessous de Maxime Lagarde à un moment
alors qu'ils sont de la même génération
et que Jules était normalement un peu au
dessus quand il était jeune bah il a
repris son rang et j'espère que ça va
stimuler Maxime Lagarde qui va y avoir
encore de beaux combats et qui vont tous
se stimuler et qu'il y aura une belle
émulation pour pour tout le monde
progresse
ça il faut le dire Juliette monstrueux
en 2022 il a gagné
je sais pas peut-être 70 points comme ça
normalement je pense là il est quasiment
200700 Hello
et il était à 26 20 comme ça je peux la
France il avait
Jules
ça va ça va trembler c'est sûr originaux
c'est le plus fort sauf si
le fait aussi là il y aurait gros combat
mais là c'est vrai que
les joueurs comme Étienne et Laurence
sont plutôt je dirais pas en fin de
carrière ce serait maladroit de dire ça
mais
mine de rien ils sont ils sont bien plus
âgés que le reste c'est à dire que
Jules est encore assez jeune pour
progresser mais sinon c'est dur ils sont
loin de leurs meilleurs hello que ce
soit Étienne ou Laurent qui ont été tout
de plus de 2700 Etienne qui était
vraiment bien au dessus de 2700 pendant
très longtemps je crois que son record
c'était 27 49
et je dirais que positionnellement
Étienne est monstrueux
donc
ça serait plutôt un style ultra
calculatoire qu'il mettra en difficulté
voilà ce que je dirais stuff
mais en difficulté
de lui demander en personne à Laurent
Laurent qui qui va stream très bientôt
d'ailleurs sur la chaîne avec toi Kevin
donc c'est le week-end prochain c'est ça
[Musique]
avec lui si c'est pas de bêtises
ok Laurent il va peut-être pas
travailler le weekend
il travaille peut-être
son tennis
alors du coup donc dame G4 le roi qui va
qui va s'échapper le roi de Magnus qui
va prendre la suite
on peut imaginer peut-être un roi
je préfère passer par e indien donc pour
éviter de perdre mon fouet
mauvaise idée parce que
tu peux faire un truc
si je crois D1 et là il y avait un
problème il y avait Dame des trois
souffle sur roi des
ok c'est un problème parce que sur échec
voilà tu as mangé là il mange là je peux
faire oui qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour me tirer des trucs
non en fait j'ai dit une bêtise tout il
y a peut-être
[Musique]
on fait un peu gaffe quand même donc
en tout cas
je peux pas le laisser faire ça en fait
je peux pas aller en
échec échec et je crois à toi donc là ça
va encore mais j'ai d'abord
du coup ça donne
la tour elle est paralysée
à base de cette cavaliers de roi des
deux donc
un tout petit peu
comme casse-gueule ce genre de position
ok JF c'est Jean-François Joly
otov qu'on va regarder aussi
qui se passe plein de choses ici
alors
c'est vite là il a mangé à 5
parce que tu disais
garde les pièces et on pousse encore
c'est Jean-François Joly le joueur
breton mettre
un énorme un énorme national bon
accession c'est pas pareil tout le monde
peut faire un très bon tournoi
relaxation enfin quand je dis tout le
monde c'est beaucoup plus commun coach
group après effectivement il a fait un
tournoi incroyable dans le a mais c'est
déjà arrivé à beaucoup de mettre un de
faire un tournoi niveau grand maître
même très fort et après de ne pas
nécessairement
confirmé voilà voilà tous les soirs sur
un tournoi il est capable d'élever son
niveau de jeu mais pas avec régularité
autre chose qu'il explique JF il est pas
pro des échecs
donc pour déjà pour confirmer faut jouer
tout le temps
c'est ça le truc quand on est accaparé
par d'autres projets on peut pas on peut
pas performer véritablement bon ça
craque un petit peu chez ergy j'ai
l'impression de souffle c'est ça c'est
dur
c'est dur mais bon
possibilité
puis il est stable ici maintenant
partie salut Benoît
il a été assez jeune de ses fans parce
que JF parce qu'il a que un an de moins
de mois donc j'estime qu'il est très
jeune même
il est un peu trop trop en retard
donc on va voir alors le classement je
vous montre si vous voulez mais très
très vite parce que là on regarde autre
chose
alors vraiment très rapidement vous avez
le classement avec Abdou qui est en tête
avec un niche aussi et premier mais anus
il y a une partie de plus et Abou qui va
peut-être gagner et s'il gagnera 5
points et demi il aura du coup un point
d'avance sur 100 pour suivant il est pas
mal en plus qui reste pas facile à jouer
donc il a pas joué
il a pas joué que les moins bons
battre les Noirs bon c'est vrai que il a
un bon style pour
pour potentiellement pouvoir perdre avec
les Blancs parce que c'est pas une
serrure c'est plutôt quelqu'un qui joue
avec les deux couleurs
mais quand même
dans l'ordi il vient de dire que F3
c'était pourri mais moi j'ai peine à
trouver le gain surtout fait j'arrive
pas du tout à trouver
on va voir voilà assister outside
on s'approche du dénouement ou du grand
moment chaud de la ronde puisqu'il reste
10 minutes à chaque joueur sur cette
position voilà
donc il y a 13 rondes
et là vous voyez qu'on est à la septième
sur 13 en haut
près du titre
et du coup là
ça va être chaud partout est-ce que
qu'est-ce que ça donne Kemer contre
digne stouf est-ce que ça ça a avancé
positivement pour Vincent Kemer ou pas
[Musique]
à la partie entre c'était
c'était Abdou ça Torin fait
où il y a eu cette
[Musique]
position un peu comme celle-là ou il va
être difficile pour les blancs de gagner
parce que les noirs sont très actifs
maintenant c'est pas impossible non plus
ils vont jouer pour cela
et Magnus est en train de finir Richard
à porte
[Musique]
sur la partie qui risque de bientôt
se terminer donc il a rendu la pièce il
a mis son rôle à l'abri hein
[Musique]
il y a eu échec échec
et il a mis le cavalier de
donc là il y a deux pions pour la pièce
mais après
si vous voulez parce que l'option E4 il
est muselé prochainement en cas d'amf2
je dois voir dame G3 sauf qui qui
clôture quasiment le débat pour pour
simplifier la pose et les pions les
pions de Richard rapportent sont pas
assez dangereux ici pour faire quelque
chose de concret
donc là ça va être dur ça va être très
très dur
il peut jouer encore longtemps cette
position
alors Prague qu'est-ce qui nous fait
Prague Prague il a mis une petite tour
en B7 ça fait plaisir on voit que les
pièces noires sont vraiment complètement
qui vient de faire le très intéressant
F3 pour aller dans ton sens stuff et
créer un deuxième foyer chaud avec un E4
rapide MP3 on en avait parlé
il prend le temps
F3 il y a toujours une découverte à un
sujet
B8 en prime parce que tous les pièces
sont mal placés d'accord
à une sorte de découverte harcèlement
alors pra qui a 3 minutes à la pendule
quand même donc il faut il faut faire
attention
il faudrait pas qu'il soit embrouiller
par un Jordan forest ce serait là la
partie a été dominée de bout en bout
un gros coup rouge alors qu'il dominait
quand même les débats plutôt tout il
avait un petit plus
et il a
laissé le cavalier rentrer en F4 après
avoir joué
après avoir joué D4 attention que les
tours noirs ne s'activent pas vraiment
qu'il a eu peur qu'on s'en fout que le
cavalier puisse pas rentrer à la maison
peut-être ça c'était une préoccupation
tour des deux derniers 5 on est plus du
tout sûr de la nul que tu annoncé tout à
l'heure comme quoi ça brille je trouve
là on voit un bouquet en grande
difficulté mais il est malade c'est son
problème dans beaucoup de parties il est
tout le temps mal au temps en fait bah
là il est mal au temps et en position
puis on a deux mois gros attaque noir
les pièces qui ne vont pas très bien
chez les Blancs donc là il est il est
dans les cordes c'est fait complètement
retourné une position assez qui semblait
assez disputé
donc là on est en train de voir que les
zaynotes arrivent et que les positions
peuvent briller
il y a pas beaucoup d'erreurs mais il y
en a quelques-unes et c'est souvent en
manque de temps qu'elles arrivent
un peu la caméra on va vous mettre un
petit peu du reggae là
montrer mettez déjà la victoire de
Magnus c'est qu'on l'aura dans le quart
d'heure
voilà
il y a 15 minutes de décalage entre ce
qu'on voit
et on va dire le
tour des 4
dommage de fou H4
au niveau du roi
grosse partie en tout cas de besoin
de précisions juste sur cette partie
s'il te plaît souffle 97 97 il laisse
pas beaucoup de place au doute quand tu
es à 97 % de précision contre un jour à
2720 avec les noirs sur 34 coups ça fait
quand même
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal en plus la
partie était chaude quoi
le contre la joie
c'était magnifique
je pense Kevin
on veut se déclouer et menacer de manger
ici
et très dur
d'être un vrai bon coup prise tout
reprendre je vais rentrer avec Madame
en escalier
ça pourrait le coup de
notre ami Abdou alors pourquoi des
blancs et les Noirs parce qu'en fait
quand elle est blanc bah tu commences à
jouer en premier donc tu as un avantage
en fait tout simplement donc perdre avec
les Blancs à ce niveau là c'est quand
même plus significatif
parce que quelqu'un censé avoir un léger
avantage au début pour nous amateur
c'est pas si important mais pour 45
quand il perd avec les Blancs c'est que
vraiment il a fait des trucs mauvais
quoi
voilà
et du coup donc ça ne rapporte là c'est
bientôt bientôt la position de faim sauf
ah oui il y a eu elle change de dames je
crois il y avait changé
d'ailleurs peut-être
et là puis on prend ça va être
parce que là pour le coup
du coup et puis les pions h et eux vont
se faire matraquer
ils vont être perdu d'ailleurs
parce qu'on voit que le rapport va
abandonner
avec 6 coups à jouer
qui devrait garder une réserve de temps
car wanna ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas
vu ouais alors du coup il y a trois
minutes pour Carona pour deux coups
donc
et c'est plus compliqué que tout à
l'heure c'est parti
il avait il avait une petite pression
carwana il a pas réussi à la maintenir
jusqu'au bout
en fait apparemment il met la pression
depuis tout à l'heure
quand on voit sauf que c'est plus
agréable à jouer
donc ils sont actifs mais il y a un pion
quand même
il y a un pion donc c'est chaud échec
voilà
sacrifié un pion pour le jeu et à chaque
coup tu dois trouver tu dois t’employer
il est mal au temple comme tu as dit
Prague il a une minute 40 pour 3 coups
pas lâcher après maintenant je peux
jamais prendre le pion à 5 donc ça reste
quand même assez facile à jouer à 5 je
tourne avec un petit clouage sur la tour
tu peux pas redescendre en plus donc là
c'est quand même confort
rassemblement
que l'avantage noir est de plus en plus
significatif
maintenant il faut terminer selon le
position c'est jamais facile
un petit clouage le plan pour Prague
Prague en fait on va jouer sur le second
foyer donc là tu as déjà un film plus un
peu passé ici et un peu en avance les
pièces noires absolument pas donc du
coup ton plan ça peut être de jouer à 4
éventuellement de monter le roi et voir
ce qui se passe mais pendant que les
pièces sont là-bas à attendre et ben du
coup tu as le temps de faire plein de
choses on va 45 qui qui gagne sa partie
je peux vous le montrer à l'écran voir
si c'est pas encore vous allez le voir
dans quelques instants
pour François il y a le principe des
deux faiblesses aux échecs c'est à dire
que là la première force blanche a
condamné les Noirs à la défense de ce
coin là donc on va considérer que le
pion A5 c'est la force blanche et du
coup considéré comme une faiblesse pour
les noirs et du coup va falloir créer un
autre foyer un autre endroit de
l'échiquier pour faire vaciller
justement la défense de l'adversaire
donc là le coup proposé partout c'était
les coups comme E4 cavaliers des trois
ramener du monde sur ce côté là pour
faire tanguer l'adversaire voilà
je crois que c'est terminé mais la
caméra ils m'ont changé là
vous pensez qu'on verra une série
d'invassibilité comme celle de Carlsen
de notre vivant
oui c'est possible si Carlsen se remet
dedans parce que voilà il a bien perdu
il a récemment donc
on sera pas évident de toute façon parce
que même pour un joueur comme Carlson
faut un peu de réussite il avait été en
difficulté dans certaines parties faudra
un grand quart de scène ou un grand je
sais pas qui mais de notre vie c'est pas
sûr c'est pas sûr
yes on travaille sur deux endroits donc
de faiblesses en règle générale mais ça
peut être une force une faiblesse de
force et c'est comme ça qu'on fait
facile et les défenses exactement
prise mais aussi celui-là en prise là
qu'on a mieux je regardais si on avait
mieux
qui a plus de temps là aussi qui a une
minute à la pendule c'est hyper chaud
oui mais je pense que sa position est
tellement détruite de toute façon que
s'il avait eu beaucoup de temps dans
cette position sauf ça aurait été une
souffrance encore plus forte presque des
fois on préfère trop de temps qu'on est
hyper mal voilà
tu vas me faire speeder un peu
l'adversaire mais bon là ça marche pas
c'est niveau amateur à ce niveau là ils
sont quand même rompus aux exercices de
jeux sous pression et si l'adversaire
est mal au temps
de poser une question Kevin
parce que
[Rires]
une chance de rejoindre la tête
alors on a parié avec Kevin Kevin
appareillé sur le fait que Carsen allait
finir avec un podium
bête hier mais j'ai cédé au Paris parce
que j'adore parler même si je sais que
je suis pas forcément bien dans le Paris
du coup ouais non il faut qu'il enchaîne
les victoires mais il peut encore
arriver il va avoir un problème c'est
que si à faire
le quasi meilleur tournoi de sa vie à
haut niveau en partie lente ben il va
pas pouvoir revenir sur la première
marche après sur le podium pour moi il
peut on vient de parier cela avec stouf
qu'il a l'air vu qu'il a gagné
brillamment aujourd'hui
ça y est il est remis dedans donc il
peut être il va être hyper dangereux
qui s'inscrire son premier tournoi
c'est hyper cool il faut que tu kiffes
et tu verras que c'est vraiment
différent
l'échec sur Internet souvent on a
l'impression qu'on a qu'on a un peu de
mal à calculer parce que le checker il
est il est bizarre en fait
en 3D au lieu d'être en 2D mais en tout
cas c'est jouer jouer en vrai en IRL
c'est 1000 fois mieux que je sur
internet donc je pense que c'est pas
meilleur
c'est juste si tu as envie de progresser
c'est le meilleur moyen enfin ça va
encore t'amener des perspectives
nouvelles et tu as trop raison
le price poule je l'ai pas
malheureusement mais je dirais que le
premier prix c'est à quoi 50 000
à peu près Kevin
les scènes
[Rires]
[Musique]
en fait j'ai rappelle-toi que ce qu'on
montre pas
encore un super conseil technique
comme j'ai revu le truc hier je me suis
dit peut-être qu'il y a un nouveau truc
quoi voilà
ce que je veux dire je fais de mon mieux
ça y est la loose en direct live après
cavalier des 6 qui a fait extrêmement
mal puisque KLD 6 va y avoir la petite
surprise en Détroit
ah oui ça pardon ça abandon parce qu'en
plus non seulement il y a une fourchette
mais en plus quand la dame bouge peut
même avoir ton projet trois
parce que
d'abord
le petit coin intermédiaire du cavalier
pour l'instant le kg 3 a été défendu
indirectement par la prise en F4 donc on
vire le cavalier F4 et on croit que j'ai
trois donc ça tu l'as annoncé il me
semble
et tu fais bien de le dire tu fais bien
de le dire mon petit sou tu vois je
t'avais dit que c'était chaud c'est
chaud c'est chaud alors jusque là tu as
fait il y avait quoi il y avait eu 45
qu'on a qu'on a eu bon tous les deux ok
donc là c'est égal
ensuite la cave je vais mettre égale
ensuite tu avais mis quoi
[Musique]
tous les deux dit nuls facile de
terminer et du coup
[Musique]
je vais mettre un mois en fait tu
devrais marquer les points je pense de
Prague et Abdou et restera kemerding
pour que je pousse pour mon résultat
mais bon sachant que ça peut être le
tien et carwana je sais pas ce qui va
faire qu'on McDo là où il était vraiment
pas mal de
mais ça fait un peu briller tandis qu'il
essaie de de défendre
comme un acrobate comme tu nous le
disais mais un acrobate qui commence à
perdre le fil c'est bien ça
joli
ici et du coup ça menace c'est quoi tu
penses à non
Hello
[Musique]
en fait
tu voulais faire non ouais j'ai oublié
ok on va voir en tout cas
il y a eu ça la partie F6 prise MH3 donc
il est peut-être faire des petites
choses
pour essayer de lutter il reste trois
minutes
à eggasi et quasiment
l'air mais en même temps on est vissé
avec les Blancs c'est super
il y a plein de pièces que je peux pas
trop bouger je suis cloué un peu aussi
c'est hyper compliqué cette position
pourquoi vous différentiel de sols
gagner perdu vous perdrez moins
commission c'est vrai mais bon parce que
là il m'en doit une trentaine et moi je
t'en dois une vingtaine
et ça
alors du coup c'est chaud là
on aime bien avec stouf
faire comme ça mais c'est vrai que c'est
ça pour chaque event parce que là on est
à trois events
de se régler en fait parce que vous
voyez bah on n'a pas pu streamer depuis
il y a eu le random il y a eu le Noël
enfin tu sais ça a l'air hyper vite quoi
finalement faut pas se faire enfumer
avec pour Abdou
est-ce que juste tu peux nous montrer ce
que ça donne par âme contre Fabiana
Karana parce que tout à l'heure c'était
chaud après tour ces deux je savais pas
trop comment il va lui arriver
il vient d'arriver au 40e coup déjà ok
alors pour ces deux il y a eu d'imbé 6
elle est hyper
[Musique]
et défend c'est compliqué pas des pièces
blanches
4 et faire des choses ça peut arriver
aussi bon pour l'instant récemment
je vois pas max de le gagner par contre
on bête avec match nul ça a l'air d'être
la logique de la position
[Musique]
on va retourner peut-être sur sur
Prague il vient d'arriver 40e Prague
et juste et merding et c'est plus une
autre c'est 141 aussi 41e et la seule
partie un bon avantage pour Kemer voilà
le le dernier zaynat on va dire avant
les finales
ou fin de partie en tout cas avec du
temps
c'est cette position là donc il a mangé
à 7 voilà au cas où un si jamais si
jamais il n'arrive pas à le mater la
finale sera peut-être gagnante avec A et
B passée c'est vraiment caractéristique
de son style on n'arrête pas de le dire
mais il croit que les pions ils mangent
tout
c'est marrant faut prendre un sac dans
cette position où tu es archi sous
pression c'est clair
on sait jamais
il faut trouver encore quelque chose ici
pour les mains donc il reste 4 minutes
40 à Abdou il a mangé 5 j'avais mon idée
roi ou deux fois trois pour essayer de
faire un bricolage souffle pour essayer
de boucher les trous avec des rustines
bah peut-être faut trois du coup ça sera
fou trois rois 2 finalement
la menace noire donc j'ai tout retroi au
four
3 chambres c'est plus bancal avec mon
avec mon fou qui est pas très bien
voilà tout est bancalin il faut 3 il
peut y avoir
ça peut
j'essaie de boucher avec des rustines
comme comme ergasis mais
c'est dur il a joué trois ça me semblait
logique dame B5 et le pion B2 va sauter
ouais donc c'est assez conforme et puis
en fait j'ai un souci encore plus
important la dame pourrait rentrer à un
souffle sur roi G2 d'un meude donc moi
j'ai un forfait
ça va peut-être être la petite tour en
G8 qui va arriver pour tourger 8 tours
G3
quand même tout le monde arrive à la
fête organisé par le roi d'irigaziz
tu vas te faire tu vas te faire croquer
ta tête
sur sa tour Eiffel exactement
la stratégie effectivement donc jouer
est-ce que c'est pas marcher ça genre
taf je fais chèque voilà et un truc
genre fou hein oh là là regarde bravo
l'idée sympa l'idée sympa elle va
marcher c'est ça je voulais mettre faire
fouet
je casse tout ça et l'idée c'est que je
vais mater mais il y a d'enfant et il y
a d'un match de du coup
F2
voilà là on doit être vraiment archi
donc là
la petite combinette on va la trouver on
s'applique dans le château aussi
d'un point F3 tours
je prends là je prends je fais fou hein
qui obstrue qui empêche la tour de
contrôler ici magnifique et je menace
maths enfin je me la dame et surtout je
me place
hyper jolie
[Musique]
là ça va être il faut juste jouer ça ça
et ça s'il joue ça ça va être abondant
mais regarde on a raté
parce que si tu prends
tous les pièces bien mises évidemment on
a des récompenses
on aura toujours de la chance quand nos
pièces sont bien placées
[Musique]
combien il a la note chaise.com pour
cette partie ce qui aura plus de 98
prises
3 au four les deux coups gagnent mais tu
reprends F3
encore plus fort
comme je pense à toi
je vais regarder avant qu'il joue un
mauvais coup
95,4
mais là je fais une partie quasiment
parfaite franchement
un coup brillant pour venir est-ce que
ça a changé les choses
il a gagné
[Musique]
5 et abandon
c'est sympa on voit la classe des deux
joueurs aussi un deux petits jeunes ils
aiment bien jouer aux échecs très calme
ils sont
[Musique]
on voit l'état d'esprit très très
fair-play voilà deux jeunes qui vont
aller extrêmement loin mais d'ailleurs
est régalez l'an dernier il faisait le
challenger non mais il a gagné avec
17000 sur 13 voilà avec avec Marc-André
maudit si je me trompe pas et c'était le
début des Regal easy enfin je veux dire
on venait d'en entendre parler depuis
peut-être le mois de décembre ou enfin
ça faisait pas longtemps qu'on
n'entendait parler et il était quoi 2600
il est 27 22 vous rendez compte les
points et l'eau qui l'a gagné du coup
c'est c'est juste incroyable
j'ai la chance de l'avoir comme comme
partenaire de club Google
en partenaire de club c'est quand même
très sympa de les avoir dans dans notre
équipe et je peux vous dire qu'ils font
des points je peux être France très très
fort
alors du coup Prague World forest
pression sur
comment est-ce qu'il va passer à un
moment il va il va pousser le cadre
avant d'aller hein
on a vraiment beaucoup de temps
peut-être même pour faire un mois cinq
fixé mais je protégerai bien je fais un
truc comme
tous les deux cavaliers B3 et après je
transfère mes pièces
en fait il va améliorer
amélioration Nantes ça va être long
encore
[Musique]
une colonne pour la tour qui peut passer
par l'autre côté et c'est vrai qu'on
voyait abdos à l'écran et Michel nous
dit qu'est-ce qu'il est stock
physiquement c'est impressionnant il
parlait d'abus à Torah
il a rien au hasard il a l'air très
sérieux sur tous les plans mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a au niveau physique il
fait bonne impression aussi
et prix est prise qui nous dit c'est
vrai mais je suis plus impressionné par
son niveau aux échecs
ah non costaud c'est vrai que le
championnat de France de Top 16 de Top
16 pardon de Division 1 donc par équipe
il est pas c'est pas la partie du
dimanche on les les rondes les 11 matchs
ont été regroupés sur 11 jours d'affilée
donc on se retrouve à un endroit
effectivement en l'occurrence ça sera à
Chartres
et du coup
[Musique]
on joue bah comme c'était un open sauf
que c'est le championnat par équipe quoi
et du coup on vient souvent avec un
effectif un peu plus important que les 8
joueurs demandaient donc cette il y a
une féminine imposée par par équipe
donc du coup on joue par équipe de 8
donc souvent le cas classique c'est pas
toujours vrai il peut y avoir deux
féminines dans une équipe mais c'est
souvent
cette gars une fille et du coup après
les les équipes viennent souvent avec
deux femmes et un effectif souvent de 8
à 10 joueurs en plus nous des avatifs de
10 12 joueurs pour les 11 jours
d'affilée voilà
Néandertal j'ai l'impression que ça t'a
plu
alors sipra gagne cette partie il va
passer à 26,98,6
normalement
presque 2700 lois un petit Prague
pas mal
à Jordan ça aurait été une belle
souffrance toute la partie il a donné
son pion a dans le début
quasiment 10/12 j'aurais dit
et le hello d'un maître vide c'est plus
de 2300 voilà ça a été dit par DC fans
fait pour être fidd il faut avoir passé
une seule fois 2300 et un site qu'on a à
vie et après c'est bien de le rester
plus de 2300 pour faire comme Stéphane